so as we're getting ready to do the show
we're doing our research of course and
there's uh two big stories that we're
trying to figure out which one makes the
most sense to start the show with it's
called the lead story and it's meant to
rope in the viewers so we can have this
this bigger conversation and the one the
first is that there's a poll that came
out showing most Americans support the
boycott against Anheuser-Busch that is
to say they're not just upset over what
Bud Light did they're actually
supporting taking political action
against this company that's most people
if most people are for the boycott you
have to imagine even more people are
actually upset I'd be willing to bet
there's a large group of people who are
like yeah it was really done what they
did but I don't care about a boycott
right the next story is about Ralph yarl
it's a teenager who reportedly went to
the wrong house and then was shot for it
the media is now drumming this up into
this big black lives matter episode
where they said that he went to the the
house rang the doorbell and This Racist
old man just shot him
but in reality there's a bunch of lies
that have come out and we're going to
break those down one The Washington Post
had to issue a correction because they
claimed the teenager was dead and he's
not he's actually recovering but then
something else happened as we're getting
ready to the show Matt Walsh got hacked
presumably unless he's just decided to
go off and start insulting I don't know
Ben Shapiro and Joe Rogan which I really
doubt but the reason I think we I
decided we should start off with this
Matt Walsh getting hacked as a for one
it just happened it's breaking right now
it's the presumption that he was hacked
we don't know for sure I reached that
daily wire crew and said hey yo check
this out you might want to get on top of
this but uh it leads directly into the
Anheuser-Busch boycott story The
backlash against those who are standing
up against gender ideology is pronounced
and so uh we will talk about that but my
friends before we get started head over
to castbrew.com and buy some of our
delicious cast Brew Coffee we are
sponsoring ourselves everybody if you go
to casper.com you can pick up your rise
with Roberto Jr breakfast blend they
come in ground or whole bean options and
I got good news
it uh so let me say these are pre-orders
production has begun and it is expected
to ship by May 5th but it's entirely
possible I don't know for sure it could
actually come earlier we got some good
news that um they may have been able to
get things done a little bit earlier but
I can't make those guarantees I'm just
letting you know so it it is your
guaranteed date is May 5th for shipping
which means it'll take however long to
get to you
um from them depending on where you're
at but uh support our new Venture
castbrewcoffee.com click the link in the
description below and also head over to
timcast.com click that join us button
become a member to get access to the
members only after show which will be
live tonight at 10 10 p.m and we'll even
be taking your phone calls if you become
a member for at least six months or the
25 level you can submit questions and
then be chosen to call into the show and
speak with us and our guest so don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about all of this and a
whole lot more is Joel Pollock
good evening who are you here senior
editor at large at Breitbart News and a
writer
and a lover of good times right on we
like Breitbart yeah we were talking
before the show about the Tea Party
Occupy Wall Street I think that'll come
up for sure it's been uh man 12 11 and a
half years since occupied and it's
interesting to see the evolution of
where we are in the culture war and just
how uh crazy it's gotten I guess but uh
thanks for coming man should be should
be interesting talk about all that and
more it's going to be great it's been an
amazing day and
the Harpers Ferry area is incredible and
I spent the day in Harpers Ferry which I
hadn't visited before and the layers of
history there are just incredible
the Revolutionary War History George
Washington set it up as the second
Armory for the United States and then of
course we learned in school about the
raid on Harpers Ferry but I actually
learned from my fifth grade daughter
this year that Lewis and Clark started
their expedition from Harpers Ferry then
you've got uh
the story College over there which is I
believe the first black college in the
United States wow historic college and
the Catholic Church there that dominates
the Skyline is
still in operation was built largely for
the Irish Catholic rail workers who
worked on the railroad so all these
different intersecting layers of
American history in one place and a
fantastically beautiful location right
there but you know why because of the
rivers it's the yeah the Confluence of
the rivers that's why did you see that
it's a strategic location for a variety
of reasons the billboard that's carved
into the mountain before they had
Billboards they actually carved there's
a giant ad in the mountain and Harpers
Ferry it's cool uh but yeah uh and the
John Brown raid headquarters just down
the street you can actually go drive
down there and then look at all the
signs walk up to the building and
everything it's pretty crazy so it's
interesting because we're going to talk
about Occupy Wall Street later is that
when occupy hit it was a phenomenon
it attracted a lot of media attention a
lot of debate
but that
root of radical protest and in John
Brown's case actual military action but
that route of radicalism is actually
pretty deep in American history it's not
necessarily new or imported the rate on
Harper's Ferry was very much a homegrown
American thing let's uh well let's let's
save and get into that later on in the
show yeah thanks for for joining us we
got Phil Labonte hanging out how you
doing Phil Labonte lead singer of All
That Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary
I'm Ian Crossland happy to be back
everybody what what a week last week but
let's stick to tonight I want to talk
more about this Harpers Ferry stuff man
absolutely this is nuts then we got
surge pressing the buttons what's up
guys uh ready to go on your Tim ladies
and gentlemen your breaking news this
happened just a few minutes ago it
appears that Matt Walsh has been hacked
on Twitter and uh we're sitting here
we're trying to figure out what the the
big story of the day is you've got
Anheuser-Busch is getting tremendous
support from the American public you've
got this story about this teenager who
was shot and then sure enough I think uh
four minutes to go or whatever Phil
Labonte he's like uh Matt Walsh just
tweeted that my pronouns are that and uh
words there's an N word and then uh he
says Joe wrote he calls Joe roganapito
he says he can confirm that Andrew Tate
kidnapped and uh raped some girls it
looks like someone might have actually
stolen his phone because they just put
up a picture that has uh someone took a
picture of what looks like it might be
his phone where people are texting him
it looks like there's a Google
authentication code in there Microsoft
account security code Twitter
authentication code so yeah I don't want
to show that yeah we got some silly
tweets where he's like he said benj
appear you know what you did and calls
him he calls him gay you know but I
don't want to pull up any of Matt
Walsh's private information but uh
ladies and gentlemen I am I am a
privileged individual in that I have the
phone numbers of people at the daily
wire and since it happened I'm sorry I
ruined the fun of whoever these people
are and I immediately called him I was
like guys uh get on this I'm assuming
they were you know it's the hardest
thing
because you never want to just be that
random nosy like I don't work as a daily
wire or anything like that for all I
know I call them and they're like yes we
know we're on it like okay bye like I
sorry to waste your time guys but I I
think they it like we caught around when
it happened and uh you know oh geez wait
okay what's a Matt Walsh blog let me I'm
pulling up Matt Walsh's Twitter account
on a separate screen because I want to
show any of his private information
yeah he's got a tweet there my Twitter
isn't hacked this is just a real me
coming out and it's a picture of that
phone and he said you should not lend
your phone to anybody in case anybody
out there doesn't it's crazy to think
how much is centralized in these phones
now yeah I mean yeah yeah but this is
this is there's no way this is a prank
this this has to be hack so I'm looking
at it right now I'm not going to show it
on the show I can't because it says uh
someone someone texted Matt and it says
your Twitter has been hacked right and
but the number isn't saved which means
they likely cloned his SIM card I'm just
gonna say it's like it might be not the
actual uh actually let me let me see if
I if I know uh whose number this is on
top of that if you look underneath there
you see like the Google verification
code Twitter authentication code so they
probably went through and reset it to
that phone in order to like you know
remake right so you can use you can do
that with the original phone and then
move it to another phone which is
probably what they did and it's happened
to me before when people have said hey I
am out of battery do you mind if I just
use your phone to make a phone call and
increase it's also on the East Coast
Matt Walsh's I don't I mean Matt Walsh
is either in LA or he's in Nashville I
thought good call yeah so it's our time
zone yeah this is our time zone so so
okay so so I'll stress this
what likely happened is uh
oh man I almost I want to describe how
to do it because I don't want to spread
that information I don't know but simply
put it is very easy to clone someone's
SIM card and once you do you can put
into any phone and then when you log
into their account you'll get all of
their passwords you'll get all of their
you'll get you you get you get
everything you get two two factor and
all that stuff so I don't know uh what
what else
uh Phil you said there's some something
else besides this image the image in the
image the time is uh East Coast time
because it was posted the picture was
posted six minutes ago in the uh in the
image it says 8 PM 801 is is when the
image was taken of the phone here yeah
yeah the reason there's there's that
reason the reason why I think this is
legit a hack is that um one the phone
number that messaged this phone and said
your Twitter has been hacked
there's no name if it was actually Matt
Walsh the name would be saved which
implies a Sim clone but then also it
shows security codes for a bunch of
different accounts and Google account
yeah right that's like leaking very
serious access and information and the
Twitter account which tells you they've
probably changed the password right at
that time 7 22 PM right Eastern so they
changed the password Twitter sent the
auto authentication code and now they're
into Google they're into Microsoft and
you know once you're into that stuff
yeah it's kind of game over yeah wow
uh it's also
man uh
what dude where's Elon Musk yes
on the horn baby well I mean if it if
they did get a you know if they actually
have the hardware or like it's probably
like you said a clone because because of
the times that's what I believe because
the time zone stuff there's not much
that anyone in particular can do he's
gonna have to make do the running around
of closing all of his accounts and
handling all that stuff individually on
a laptop or whatever is going to come to
call all of his banking stuff it's going
to be a huge headache
good luck that's so weird why would they
post this photo if they actually hacked
it that's like when you said they posted
the picture of a phone I'm like why
would someone give up like they're
they're incriminating themselves or
making it much easier to find out who
did this
well Kellen just mentioned me that
there's uh bio and tree references some
rapper named like I don't want to say
the name of it um but according to him
it says that the bio and tweet
references some some rapper I don't want
to say the name and then it links to the
the
um Spotify for that rapper right really
right it says on the thing you can see
sassy Shooters little hack job I I just
I'm clicking no links
I imagine that it wouldn't actually be
the person that did the because this is
politically motivated it's Matt Walsh
obviously and so they just probably you
know got some random dudes rapper you
know that said that's got a mixtape or
whatever or something like that
um
but I don't imagine that the actual
rapper got a hold of his thing and is
like yo I'm gonna get Matt Walsh's
information so that way I can actually
promo my mixtape I just feel like it's
more about you know getting at Matt
Walsh because he's Matt Walsh but the
promo is very telling that's and they
they splattered their promo multiple
times on the Twitter page already I mean
yeah I don't know about that like frame
somebody you know what I mean that's a
good point I mean maybe you know why how
do you protect your sim card oh sorry to
interrupt is this is this indicative
that his phone was out of his hands when
it was taken no no no it was crazy I
don't want to describe how easy it is to
do man I like I
I will say this
you don't need the device
you don't need any physical object
you only need a phone number that is so
crazy man that's it this world where we
think we have any kind of security it's
all oh no yeah it's all an illusion
there is no security anymore the idea of
security security is
always what can you air gap
if you don't have an air gap then you do
not that means that means it has to be
only Hardware has to have no Wi-fi
ability plug-in only and you own you
never plug it into like some kind of
internet that you don't know I mean it's
super hard to be here's the other thing
to consider
all of Matt Walsh's direct messages have
just been exfiltrated
like
yeah
so all that stuff I said to Matt if you
guys end up reading it it's totally a
joke
no I I was like I I was I was thinking
that I've only the only thing I've ever
said was uh like good movie guy or
something like that Matt Walsh is uh his
uh his direct messages and stuff they're
probably one step more edgy than Mitt
Romney
you know I didn't know about that I
because I just I he's like you know I
mean he probably gets fired up and says
some bad things about trans people but
other than that which the trans people
are are already completely convinced
that he's gonna say that you know the
most terrible things you could possibly
say about them from you know Matt Walsh
so I'm like do I need to try and should
I do something I don't know you know
part of me is kind of like is mind my
own business stay out of it I I felt bad
enough actually calling the daily wire
guys and being like hey I do you guys
know this because I feel like it's
intrusive I mean it was right but like I
could also reach out to
people at Twitter and be like hey you
know but I'm like is it my place I I
don't imagine that there's a whole like
I said I don't imagine that there's a
whole lot that can be done like the real
damage is the stuff that they've got
behind the scenes never mind his Twitter
account sure it explodes this stuff but
you know the other thing right to
consider this
whoever did this they probably did a lot
more before revealing that they did it
if they're smart yeah yeah
I can't believe they posted this image
of the phone though I mean that just
give so much away 7 22 PM is when they
when they when they broke in hacked is
already trending of 40 000 tweets about
it wow man yo this is crazy what's going
on
but this is uh uh so you know this just
happened and I think this is an element
of
look we saw Riley Gaines try to give a
speech and they threatened her life they
chase her into a room she gets locked in
what was it like three hours she's
locked in as people are screaming and
demanding money yeah this is another
component look people get hacked all the
time I don't want to act like you know
what's happening to Matt Walsh is like
the first time anyone's ever been hacked
or whatever but you got to recognize I
mean for us here we've been swatted we
were swatted 15 times in a year yeah
this is the stuff that comes with the
territory
it's like like you said fifth
generational Warfare this is part of it
it's it's not an actual it's not combat
but it's it's it's definitely a part of
the culture War it's I mean it's
ridiculous to think that it that it
wasn't you know it's Matt Walsh he's
like well I suppose we'll just uh keep
this one in the on the on the back
burner to see if there's any updates and
developments uh what's going on but the
time being it just looked like that's
the last tweet 12 minutes ago saying I
wasn't hacked as a picture of my phone
that's so weird that's crazy
yeah man posting other other security
codes and stuff like that I guess we'll
see but let's um we'll just we'll jump
into the next story and we'll uh we'll
come back to this one if more
developments come in
this is what it's all about right here
take a look at the story from the Daily
Mail
Bud Light boycott I'll drink to that
pole finds most Americans back
Anheuser-Busch snub over its tie up with
Dylan Mulvaney and say corporations give
transgender rights too much attention
take a look at this do you support or
oppose the boycott of Anheuser-Busch 37
strongly support 17
somewhat support now here's the best
part
you then have uh the like the not sure
segment of people is the smallest
you've got 18 strongly opposing it 12
somewhat opposing it so you you you're
looking at the majority of people are
saying outright we are in favor of this
boycott and that says a lot yep how many
people is uh it was a survey of 1 000
people 1 000 adults from Rasmussen and
it found that 54 of people uh supported
it so Rasmussen actually tends to be
decently accurate surprising uh I would
say surprisingly not the right word
um in in this regard we take a look at
like a lot of the uh election data and
Rasmussen is is fairly close in terms of
getting the the actual results right so
I would agree with this you know and and
just real quick to uh shout out Jesse
Kelly when he said the first time his
neighbors ever asked him about politics
was because of Bud Light so this
absolutely lines up can I just point out
one flaw in the poll and this is not a
knock on Rasmussen but don't you have to
ask beer drinkers because this is asking
adults it's a thousand adults and that's
the problem we always have with these
political polls that come out when they
try to push people one way or another
they say we pulled a thousand adults
about Trump well adults aren't
registered voters and registered voters
aren't likely voters and it's not the
best sampling it's not no but I disagree
uh I don't drink but I'm a beer buyer we
we typically would have a beer stocked
here we haven't done a little bit but we
would go out to different breweries in
the area and we'd pick up cases of beer
because we have guests and we have
people humans like beer you know so I
think it's fine you know just because I
think about think of this way too let's
say I don't know what percentage of
people don't drink beer at all right
they're going to go out with their
friends still and they're going to be
like hey don't buy that they're going to
support the boycott well some of us
don't drink light beer at all
tend to not take polls too seriously
unless they're it like huge but like a
thousand people I'm just kind of like eh
and you're right maybe none of them
drink or ever did and ever will so like
I don't know and I want to make not make
the mistake of wanting to believe a poll
that I like just because it's something
an outcome that I like
um well here's the problem with the
boycott that we found at Breitbart from
day one you're not going to drink Bud
Light oh well let's look at these other
brands oh they're all also owned by
Anheuser-Busch so inbev yeah yeah it's
it's very very hard to find an
alternative if you like that now there
are alternatives out there but I think
it brought home to people how few big
companies are actually in this market
and that in turn brought home
the fact that the political agenda that
companies are often indulging in has
become so Universal because there are so
many Industries we have this amount of
concentrated commercial power that they
can change the culture so easily with
one ad campaign now I don't know if they
succeeded in this one there's a backlash
but from their perspective it might
actually be a successful marketing
campaign because they've raised brand
awareness to new heights people are
talking about their beer I don't think
so maybe maybe but if unless they come
out with a with an apology then it's
just very very negative I mean you got
Rhonda Sanders coming out today I think
it was today and he said I'm not going
to buy their beer anymore why would I
like it's just cascading and normally
these stories they don't last three
weeks when we get him to ban that beer
at Disney World then we can put this all
in one story that's what does it not the
prison like maybe they need a new prison
next to what is it was it called
something Creek OH Reedy Creek or
whatever really I said they should call
the prison the Correctional Center
that's great I I initially thought that
this was going to be received as a an
attack on Dylan and so I was kind of
against the idea of boycotting because I
was like people are going to take it as
an attack on Dylan they're going to take
it as as uh you know the right being you
know mean-spirited Etc and I was like
this isn't going to go well it's going
to look bad and I'm happy to say that it
looks like I'm I'm wrong I think that
the the general uh population doesn't
feel like you're they're bullying Dylan
Dylan I think they feel like the the
problem is with bud and I think that you
know that that's showing in you know in
the polls and stuff for me I think my
conscience is cleared in that we talk
about it as in as if the the beer
company got a guy that targets children
as his main audience to sponsor beer
which I don't care if you're gay or
trans or whatever your sexuality or or
gender or whatever I really don't if
you're a good person it's if things like
this misalignment where little kids are
getting fed beer ads or their favorite
influencer is selling beer and they see
them drinking it in the tub and they're
like nine like that that's where I think
they made a huge mistake and I do not
fault Dylan although uh for that aspect
of it although I don't like that he
without maybe even realizing it is has
kids as his little audience and is
selling beer but I mean you know he's
he's in a meteoroic rise state right now
and probably doesn't have a lot of
advisors around him that he can trust
Ali London has done some digging and
found various posts from Dylan Mulvaney
lying and so the whole thing in my
opinion is is a bit and and and more
evidence backs it up uh apparently there
was an old post Dylan Mulvaney has
deleted some of these old posts and I
think the reason is Dylan tried doing
like made a post about being trans and
having trouble getting acting work but
then later made a coming out as trans
also said on the Rosie O'Donnell podcast
whatever show that is
that that just started they just came
out publicly for the first time and just
started taking hormones in this one
video and then Ollie was like but if you
go back you can see that Dylan Mulvaney
was was I'm sorry in the podcast I think
domoveny says they were taking the uh uh
estrogen and other pills but then on
Tick Tock there's a video where Dylan
claims they just started what I've
actually heard from some transgender
individuals they don't believe that
Dylan's actually taking any estrogen at
all based on you know Dylan Mulvaney's
body and appearance they think it's it's
it's not true he's too bony I don't know
I don't know about what that reasoning
is but the the thing I pointed out uh
the other day is that someone with like
someone with body dysmorphia
gender dysphoria or anorexia or whatever
is not going to make a video to 10
million people pointing to the thing
that triggers their dysphoria or
dysmorphia like Dylan muldaney does yeah
he's so lighthearted and joyful about
that he's a woman no no says he's a
woman like no that is a man that is a
man so my point is this he's like look
I'm a girl no no no no no you'd be like
what that's what I'm saying when Dylan
Mulvaney made the video pointing to his
dick and said women have bulges look at
it look at it look at it people with
dysphoria don't do that because it gives
them dread and anxiety that's kind of
the point so this is what I was this is
what I was told by a trans woman she
said that
Dylan Mulvaney doing that
immediately revealed that this person is
not trans because that is like the
antithesis of why someone would consider
getting surgery to remove that body part
the idea that someone would be driven
mentally to the point where they want to
amputate their genitals and then to have
someone like Don Mulvaney point to it on
camera to 10 million people that's the
antithesis of of being trans that's what
was told to me I'm not trans I don't
know I could be wrong I'm just saying I
don't think it makes sense and so
ultimately what it comes down to is I
hate talking about the individual but
this is a bigger story in how the
algorithm is ruining the minds of
children and it's like you add on all
the all the creepy nonsense they're
jamming down children's throats young
girls getting Tourette Syndrome young
girls getting weird surgeries and lip
fillers and now you want them getting
drunk man they are really trying to hurt
kids
and I think the real issue here for
conservatives is the fact that all this
is about kids and that's obscured by the
left deliberately and by the White House
extremely deliberately yeah no it's just
I was watching the White House Press
briefing a day or two ago and they were
talking about how the Republican
governors in the red states are passing
all these anti-lgbt laws 400 laws or
something like that and they
lump in the LGB with the T and they make
the T all about transgenderism as
opposed to kids and having kids exposed
to certain things I think
it's depressing actually to watch all
this rhetoric get thrown around because
none of it gives any credit to
conservatives for just caring about kids
rightly or wrongly I mean if you agree
or disagree or whatever but you have to
at least recognize that the motivation
is to protect children and yet it's
being described in exactly the opposite
way that conservatives are the ones and
I like the word use bullying kids that's
the word that they're using very
effectively that Republicans and
conservatives and people who are against
all this are the bullies there there are
a lot of stories coming out from D
transitioners that are really really
horrifying Andy no tweeted one and it
got deleted and I guess because the
individual posted it started getting too
much attention but you see a lot of
these stories from males and females
talking about how it was a huge mistake
they were confused kids going through
puberty and they were lied to and now
their lives are forever ruined the crazy
thing to me is when you get someone
who's say 15 years old and then they
sterilize that person they're not going
to know what they've lost for a for a
while and I can't imagine I just
couldn't imagine I've seen more than
enough stories isn't heard from more
than enough people who find out rather
accidentally that they're sterile
infertile or otherwise and it's always
seen as like a very devastating story
like they can't have kids there's always
always these tropes about uh how about
the movie Dogma the woman says that her
husband left her because she found out
she couldn't have kids and he didn't
want to be with someone who couldn't
that's like a portrait is a very deeply
negative thing but now all of these
young people they're going to grow up
and they're going to be like yeah I
can't have kids and in fact for many of
these young people someone like jazz
Jennings they can't actually even
experience sexual sex at all
uh the the situation the more I learn
details about jazz Jennings the more
appalling it sounds the the
the mother talking about the the uh
what's it called
whatever the expander is or whatever
dilator dilator that's what yeah oh
there's so much more too because here's
the thing you know conservatives don't
watch that show I am just
and I think now people are starting to
realize like maybe we should watch that
because when this clip went viral
showing the mother say that she
basically is like abusing Jazz it's a
crazy clip she says she'll like hold her
down and force this thing into a wound
to force the wound to stop healing it's
like it's crazy I think then it's Ryan
too yeah and and where are we as a
society to be like this has to stop
this is the crazy thing to me I'm
thinking right now about I'm still
thinking about what we were just talking
about I'm happy to move on if you guys
want to but it's about bullying you
brought guys brought up bullying because
you're saying like the left is claiming
that people the the conservative people
are bullying the transgender Community
but like we're here talking about no
it's about selling like twisting kids up
when they're young that's the problem
but I'm looking at Matt Walsh's Twitter
from April 17th and it says a tweet this
is to win with this Bud Light situation
is when they publicly apologize for
promoting transgenderism which that's
not about her it has nothing to do with
kids he is actually saying he's angry
that the transgender the concept of
transgenderism is being promoted he
didn't say that he just said in general
now I'm wondering if a 20 year old guy
rocks a musician got a Bud Light
contract would anyone even make a noise
about it
if his if his fans were 15 year olds I
don't think anyone would even care
because he's just a regular time but
it's Dylan Mulvaney with a dress on so
now it's getting a lot of attention I I
absolutely would take issue with a 20
year old musician selling beer 21 but I
or or any any I I don't care if the
guy's 60 years old for some reason his
audience is 15 I think it's a bad thing
the issue is how how notable is that
individual in the culture War for us to
even notice it's happening just because
I didn't know the thing it doesn't mean
I'm okay with it and this is an argument
that left uses all the time where
they're like if you're so concerned
about that what about this and it's like
wow thank you for bringing that to my
attention I am also appalled by that
they do this thing where they're like
drag queen story our concert are so mad
about this but I don't see them
complaining about children beauty
pageants and it's like what it's like 20
years ago I mean my friends were smack
talking child booty Pages as being gross
we'll still do it today they're just not
that big they're not that prominent
they're not in the National conversation
but I got no problem saying those things
are nasty and I got no problem saying
little boys should be going to Hooters
as like an appropriate place to get
thinner but that being said as much as
the left likes making that argument I'm
like dude women having boobs and a
restaurant just having women there is
very very different from having Kink
shows for children so I want to bend
this metaphor a little if a 24 year old
musician with fans that are younger got
a Bud Light contract with anyone blink
an eye yes but the thing is you can't
quantify the age of the fans you just
don't know we can with Tick Tock you
know we did this we had this debate a
little bit over cigarettes right they
canceled Joe Camel about I don't know 15
years ago because the cartoon image of
the camel was thought to appeal the
children and so the maker of those
cigarettes I can't remember which
company made camel makes camel it's just
camel they they got rid of Joe Camel and
for that reason because even though it
wasn't appearing in children's media
kids were seeing the Joe Camel and
thinking okay there's this cartoon that
they associate with cigarettes by the
way you know let's be real like James
Bond was a bigger influence in getting
kids to smoke than Joe Camel was if I
was 20. seriously I was an actor in my
early 20s I mean I'm still an actor but
I was in Hollywood for a lot of that and
if I'd booked a Bud Light commercial at
the age of 25 and people went nuts on me
because some of my fans were 16 and 17.
that's I would be out of my mind pissed
off at them yeah I'm over 21 man I'm
selling beer right that's not it Dylan
Mulvaney is on Tick Tock with 11 million
followers and outside of Dylan Mulvaney
the average Tick Tock user is 20 years
old that means if you were to take every
single person using the platform which
includes adults it still skews young and
Dylan Mulvaney's audience at the very
least is underage and and should not be
drinking yeah well let's be real they
Bud Light Anheuser-Busch they all know
kids who are 89 drinking and my personal
opinions of drinking age should be 18
and people shouldn't drink either way
but if you're an adult you should be
allowed to the point is delmovie's
audience audience isn't 20 years old
that's the tick tock average Dylan
mulvania's audience skews much lower
than that and it's probably closer to
15.
you know and even then I wouldn't I
wouldn't blame the guy for having a
young audience and I don't think it's
that big it's that he dressed up as a
little girl Eloise and did a video a
month or so ago pretending to be a
little girl that's what the Benny sells
beer the next month remember the guy who
drew who was the the trans little girl
that old guy let me pull this thing up
oh God you know the whole drag queen
Story Hour is also interesting because
the whole drag phenomenon has changed as
well
there is video of Donald Trump sitting
on the couch I can't remember what talk
show it was but next to Dame Edna I
don't know if you remember Dame Edna you
know uh famous drag queen there you go
here you go everybody and it was it was
just kind of ordinary like Rudy Giuliani
dressing in drag on Saturday Night Live
and again it's about adults and it's
it's not a show meant for kids but but
the
the stripteases and the the Kink shows I
think are again when kids are coming to
that are being brought to that that's
what people are objecting to not drag in
general right and and uh interestingly
even some Democrats don't want drag for
anybody I think it's eight percent we
were we were talking about this the
other day most Americans 52 think drag
should just be for adults a large
portion are unsure and then it's like 24
think anyone should be able to see a
drag show even a child but those are of
course Democrats and a small portion of
Independence yeah we had the story from
a while ago this is a a guy who lives as
a six-year-old girl
like sure whatever man I do your thing
in fact I got a Bud Light contract I'd
be pissed because he's he's dressing as
a six-year-old I I actually would not
really yeah no I dude I don't care like
remember Jack Daniels uh uh people were
talking about floating the idea of
boycotting Jack Daniels because they
sponsored RuPaul drags right drag race
nobody cares
cared was like Hey look what they did
and everyone was like yeah
care that much
National wave of outrage when people
found out about that because RuPaul's
Drag Race is a bunch of adults right and
then you also had uh Coors Light did a
Pride Commercial some people pointed out
that even Yingling has had as a Pride
Commercial before nobody cares there's
also a distinction from trans to drag
exactly there's you know the issue is I
think twofold the first is that Dylan
Mulvaney is I I I think mocking women
intentionally making it making it and
trans people and targeting children but
also let's just be real Dylan Mulvaney
is very annoying to people it's and I'm
trying to be mean when I say that I'm
saying people describe Donna's Nails on
a chalkboard this this I like him what
he's like a theater guy I would have
went to school with me what I see is
with Dil Mulvaney I see Tick Tock
exploiting someone who is clearly unwell
like the the Bud Light commercial he was
just like shaking back and forth and
doing these weird Motions like
something's wrong and normally if we saw
someone like on The Price is Right
rolling on the floor screaming at the
top of their lungs I'm not kidding watch
The Price is Right video of domovany
dillable Vani more than one occasion
screams the top of his lungs like and
normally if you saw someone do that
you'd be like I think this person is in
need of some kind of help he was on
Ellen DeGeneres this dude has clearly
got some kind of narcissistic
personality disorder they are feeding
this stuff to two kids that is why I'm
upset now obviously Matt Walsh is upset
with gender ideology being pushed but
I've said it before and I'll say it
again that means a lot to be be mad and
see whatever he wants to see but I've
said this when he talks about Dylan
Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney does not
represent trans people right not not in
the slightest it is this weird mockery
it it is it's almost trans face it's
like this dude singing about his bulge
isn't like come on man like there I I
think the left it goes way overboard
with a whole bunch of this stuff I think
they lose it when they support people
like Dylan Mulvaney but there is a fair
point to be said that there are many
trans people who use bathrooms and no
one says anything like no one knows
maybe and no one exactly exactly so when
you see Dylan Mulvaney putting on this
performance which makes trans people
look like Psychopaths to the point where
it's easy to attack the entirety of all
transgender people it's like okay that
that's why Dylan Mulvaney is a problem
so I'll put it this way and always
always to to to rope in our good friend
Blair white in this one but it's because
Blair white is our friend that I want to
bring this up
Blair White's super awesome and not not
doing any of this weird crazy garbage
nonsense there's a whole bunch of
individuals Sarah Higdon we had on the
show totally rational reasonable people
who aren't rolling on the ground
screaming and then Dylan Mulvaney goes
on camera and just becomes a caricature
of the most insane depiction of whatever
this is enough to the point where it's
it's the primary focus of when
conservice is trying to say like hey
this is our problem with gender ideology
bro how much of that is baiting the
conservatives I mean they've
successfully now involved the whole
conservative movement in reacting and
outrage to a Tick-Tock character how
much of it is a successful marketing
Ploy or even a political plan to rile up
conservatives using the most egregious
example let's say of one category of it
and then we go for it and then Gavin
Newsom piles on and everybody else piles
on and they talk about Republicans
bullying people and suddenly
the younger voters are convinced that
Republicans are awful people who don't
understand social media and don't
understand them that was a problem with
conservatives when I was like in 20 2005
when I was you know Hallmark liberal
they were so easy to upset if I made fun
of Jesus I could rile up so predictable
they were just so overly sensitive
reactionary just so easy to take control
of those people and it is something
people need to work on one of the
reasons people might be as sensitive
about this issue in particular and Tick
Tock is just a degree to which parents
watch their kids on devices during the
pandemic and parents are hypersensitive
right now to everything that's being fed
to kids on social media there's a huge
problem right now of school refusal kids
who were on their devices for two years
and now have to go back to school and
just simply refuse to sit at a desk and
listen to a teacher and participate in
class and so the devices have become
much more a part of kids everyday
reality and I think that might also be
driving some of this not necessarily the
transgender stuff but you've got this
person who is influencing kids now
they're representing an alcoholic
beverage or whatever whatever and
parents are
freaked out maybe a little more than
usual because it agreed to which they've
seen their kids lives taken over by
devices and social media I agree I have
to imagine and some people watching
maybe maybe even have experienced this
one day you ask your kid like what do
you look at and they're like oh don't
Mulvaney and they're like oh and they
look and it's Dylan Mulvaney drinking
beer and being like Bud Light oh and
they're like Whoa man
like I don't maybe you shouldn't be on
this app if it's if it's some some adult
guy dressed like a little girl trying to
convince you to start drinking booze
something about that just doesn't seem
right I think a lot of parents are
that's probably why this reached a level
of regular Americans are saying they
support a boycott of Anheuser-Busch
Nike I I I think another good example of
why this is the case is Nike because
people did get mad that Don Mulvaney was
sponsored by Nike but that one didn't
really go anywhere either because that
wasn't targeting children it was just
kind of insulting women but you know the
women didn't get pissed off enough
going after kids and telling them to
drink and basically insulting March
Madness and the core demographic of just
like middle-aged white dudes who drink
beer really really bad play on this one
uh so anyway that that being said the
latest news on the Matt Walsh hack is uh
they've deleted all of the bad all of
the Hacked tweets are gone
looks like the account is back to normal
I hope uh he gets his phone back or
whatever and it looks like it's just the
last tweet is you know he's going to be
speaking University of Iowa they still
got to fix his uh bio
yeah I'm just gonna say oh yeah yeah up
next
he said he's still speaking at the
University of Iowa tomorrow night let's
let's let's let's jump from this and go
into the the other really big story and
I got to be honest I kind of wanted to
lead with this one and um part of me
really despises the idea that we would
lead lead with it at all but I think we
have to because this is a story about
Ralph yarl I'm not interested in talking
about the story of a teenager getting
shot why
because teenagers get shot out of time
because trespassers get shot all the
time and these stories aren't always
Justified Hero Stories sometimes they're
tragic stories of accidents why did this
story get national attention
it makes no sense
why I I've I've grown up in Chicago I
can't tell you how many times there's
stories of a white dude shooting a black
kid or a black guy shooting a white kid
or something like that happening and no
one in the in the country cares about it
but this one time this one story all of
a sudden becomes a major headline it's
almost like they're trying to distract
from something they're trying to capture
media attention or push some some
objective or or agenda or something like
that and uh I gotta tell you
I'm not super uh concerned about this
story let me see if I have a the other
story
uh what do we got is it is it over here
no it's not there is it uh actually I
don't know if I have it pulled up the
tweet I was gonna pull up I referenced
earlier is uh a woman being mercilessly
beaten in Chicago by a large group of
black teenagers now hold on a lot of
people pointed out she's not actually
the subject of the beating she's just
being attacked so that they can beat
someone else and I'm just like much
better yeah okay like wait what so the
video is they grab her by the neck and
they uh uh pull her buy her neck back
and then slam her to the ground or
something and then I guess start
pummeling and beating some guy and that
we're supposed to be like oh okay
grabbing this woman by the throat and
slamming to the ground and then stomping
on this guy is is it's all it's oh it's
okay now but my point is this
why didn't any of these stories about
the cars getting torched become the
national conversation where was the
activists protest where was the outrage
I think this explains it why is this
story in the news because protesters Pro
people protested when when a white woman
gets beat in Chicago can you rely on any
conservative to go march on the streets
of course you can't they don't care
they'll post on Twitter and go man look
at that and then they'll crack open a
Bud Light and have a sip okay maybe not
so but so much Bud Light anymore but
some of them still are probably cracking
open Bud Light being like what do I care
and that's and that's the issue the left
is fervent and willing to push and fight
for anything and the right is kind of
just like meh what am I gonna do about
it right here we are there's definitely
a movement to transform the United
States government into something more
mob rule I think with mass movements and
and pressure and that's why they're so
active do it trying to do it well those
of us who know and love Chicago and I
also grew up in Chicago
Chicago suburbs Oak Park and Skokie
I do have the video actually we can pull
it up we
understand that where all this happened
was by Millennium Park which is
basically the Heart of the City it's the
touristy area and it's shocking that
something like that would happen there
and it's a repeat in a sense of the 2020
riots when looters went down Michigan
Avenue this was no longer confined to
the South side and the West Side this
was now happening in full View and it's
one of the reasons people voted out Lori
Lightfoot but they've voted in Brandon
Johnson who's even more to the left and
yeah but he's been saying crazy things
about this but you know why
unions I mean basically no no it was it
was all race we we tried I tracked the
um the racial uh uh the voting patterns
and then the racial demographics of
Chicago and it's one for one the The
Only Exception is the university area
overtly voted for Johnson whereas every
other part of the city basically just
voted for like the white neighbors voted
for the white guy the uh Hispanic areas
voted for Hispanic guy in the black
neighborhoods voted for the for Lori
Lightfoot so my prediction was if all
the black neighborhoods top three
candidates were all black
even though like so in in the heart of
the black neighbors of Chicago
their their first choice was Lori
Lightfoot their second choice was
Brandon Johnson the third choice was you
know some other guy but
when you look at how they voted though
the white candidates don't even register
at all right voting in Chicago is kind
of a racial census and always has been
Paul Salas the guy who lost narrowly
lost in this election is the latest in a
long line of liberal white reformers in
Chicago who can't get elected and valis
is a household name in Chicago because
he ran the Chicago Public Schools he was
appointed by Mayor Daley and Daley ran
the Chicago machine it was corrupt but
he ran it with some nod at least toward
the idea that residents deserve some
value for their services and he
appointed Valles to clean up Chicago
Public Schools he did a pretty decent
job obviously they're still not great
but you just can't win running in a
general election in Chicago like that
the only reason Rahm Emanuel did is he
was seen as Obama's surrogate in Chicago
and that's why he got elected so my
prediction was if the university sector
is going to vote for Brandon Johnson
and the black neighborhoods are going to
vote for whichever candidate who's
running is black and the white
neighborhoods are going to vote for
whichever candidate is white it's going
to be Brandon Johnson who wins because
the tiebreaker goes to the far left
extremists conservatives don't have any
footprint don't have any organizing
don't have any base so the only
politically active sector was the far
left extremists and so it was fairly
obvious who was gonna who's gonna break
the tie right and the white voters in
Chicago very few of them are
conservative it's not like the racial
breakdown maps onto any kind of
political breakdown the irony is that
Chicago White Liberals are very far to
the left as you mentioned around the
universities and things like that so
for them they hate conservatives I'm
generalizing of course there are some
conservatives there are some Republicans
but they would never be caught dead
voting for a Republican and yet they're
stuck in this kind of racial Vortex
where they're living in a city where
they basically have this democracy that
doesn't work yes they threw out the bad
mayor but they're going to get someone
who's possibly even worse I'll take
let's pull this image back up you can
see it right here and I I have one thing
to say to this one thing to say to this
uh actually let me let me ask you uh
Joel does that does that screenshot
anger you in any way does it make you
angry absolutely it does it's awful that
anybody gets beaten up like that and
well I I I got to stop you right there
do you not believe that women have the
right to vote
of course they do okay well then why are
you why are you angry are you angry that
This Woman's choice you think is wrong
no no I respect This Woman's right to
choose and if she voted for this well
who am I to be angry that she's getting
what she voted for right
women have agency they can vote for
whatever they want and I believe that if
I were to make a wager on who she voted
for likely she voted for the Democrats
like she probably voted for uh Brandon
Johnson I mean that's the most likely
the guy won so my view is this obviously
no one seriously wants anyone to get
attacked like that but at a certain
point I have to say I will not project
my values onto someone else we will go
and vote and then if you if you are
successful in you know supporting your
ideas you win
I look at the people of Chicago with all
the rioting and the Looting the
vandalism the chaos and the shootings
and I'm just like once again the people
of Chicago have gotten what they voted
for why should I be upset about that I
don't live there you know like if a
bunch of people in France voted to make
it so that everybody gets a free
baguette in the morning I'm not going to
complain about it I'm not gonna cry and
scream and demand an end to socialism
I'm like I don't know I don't live in
France so let them let them vote for
what they want
the tragedy is that so many people who
just want to live regular lives are
leaving these places so there's almost
no Prospect of political change and it's
possible you might have seen Republican
candidates for example do better in the
midterms in some of the blue states of
the Northeast if more people hadn't
moved to Florida and you know good for
them but these these places are not
benefiting from democracy because yes
they can sometimes get rid of the worst
candidates but they can't elect anyone
who's going to make a difference and
make anything better and so there's this
vortex in these cities and states that
are just going to continue to fail and
what you saw this week with the
house Judiciary Committee having those
hearings on crime in New York was that
as Mark Levin pointed out it took a
house Republican majority to give voice
to these Democratic voters in New York
City who had been ignored by their own
party for decades and who finally had a
chance to tell their story and all
Democrats could tell them was that they
were props for Donald Trump that is
hilarious smart brilliant masterful move
by Republicans to say we're going to
come in here and we're going to try and
address the issues that are concerning
to you brilliant yeah and it took them
to do it but there's no mechanism in
these cities to make these people's
lives any better and and yes they keep
voting in the same governments but
they're not really presented with with
choices let me ask you are you for uh
Trump or DeSantis
Trump right now Trump uh if Trump gets
elected in 2024 and then as soon as he's
inaugurated in 2025 he immediately
begins arresting these politicians in
New York and Chicago and la and SF and
and then appointing interim government
would that be a bad thing I don't think
he should arrest them but I think he can
like Cuomo
Cuomo well which one the uh the the
politician the former Governor he's sort
of he killed a bunch of people in
nursing well okay I think it's tough to
call for the arrest of the opposition
but I think he could certainly take
legal action against these cities one
thing he should I wish he would do or
would have done but let me let me just
finish the thought I think there are
other things the federal government can
do that have nothing to do with dealing
with opposition politicians I think FEMA
should come into LA and declare it a
disaster for the homeless problem it's
the only way we're going to solve the
homeless problems but that level of
intervention but my question was would
it be a bad thing I think so I think you
can't arrest the opposition I I didn't
like it when Trump said a lot of crimes
they committed
I don't know if you define that as a
crime if you're in political office and
you make terrible terrible mistakes like
Andrew Cuomo made with sending but he
was told he was going to kill people he
was warned by his medical advisors that
putting coveted patients in nursing
homes would kill them and he didn't want
to put he had the Comfort ready ready
and available and the Javits Center and
I guess he didn't want Trump to get a
victory so my view is will people
testify to that that was in the news I
don't know I was like no you know times
reported I'm pretty sure that he was one
he was warned fairly early on but at
that stage though I think there was so
much conflicting advice I'm not trying
to make excuses for him and actually I
was one of the people who reported
pretty extensively on that story of the
nursing homes in New York
but I just don't know that you can hold
politicians criminally liable for
terrible policy mistakes as long as
they're not breaking the law
um so obviously one of the worst
decisions made during covet was that
decision especially when they had the
army field hospital and so forth but God
the the reason I ask is that uh if
the reason I ask is because quite
literally what the Democrats are doing
yes is going after their opposition with
with arresting them like targeting Trump
specifically right but they won't they
obviously won't stop there they're gonna
they're look at look at how they handle
the protest of the Supreme Court
Justices homes law enforcement for
antifa non-existent law enforcement for
proud boys lock them up so it's active
and it's happening and conservatives are
the ones who play the game where it's
like well we shouldn't we shouldn't
return uh those tactics we shouldn't do
the same thing and it's like okay well
you know Trump will be convicted there
is no circumstance in my mind where a
New York jury will acquit Donald Trump
that just seems impossible to me but
maybe I'm wrong about that and then
people are going to be like well it's a
state state issue so he can't be part of
the federal level so if he gets elected
he'll be in prison in New York New York
city or state so I don't know how that
works but they're doing it they've been
doing it and then I look at what's going
on in all these cities
and I'm not going to sit here and say
that I think it'd be a good thing that
you get some like autocrat to go and
start purging and getting rid of the
opposition or anything like that because
they would do the same thing
but I kind of feel like at this point
that's the only thing that's going to
happen you either it's going to be
Democrats don't get Republicans like
they're already doing now or Republicans
doing the Democrats it doesn't matter
what you think is good doesn't matter uh
what you want to happen what what
matters is Democrats are currently doing
it and Republicans don't then
Republicans will just be the ones
getting locked up and then you'll live
under the booth I don't understand a
party I don't disagree with you I mean
I've actually said publicly that once
they indicted Trump I said well the very
first thing that should happen when a
new Republican Administration takes over
whether it's Trump or somebody else's
they should immediately indict an arrest
Joe Biden and his family for all the
influence peddling they've done for all
the financial crimes and that's not
that's not speculative you know that's
that's
public record I hear Democrat
spokespeople going on Fox and saying
things like well where's the evidence
well you know the laptop you've been
ignoring for three years as you know for
one thing so I think they've set a
precedent and the only way you get back
to a reasonable middle is if the
Democrats know that you're capable of
retaliating I think that's one of the
reasons there's still a filibuster by
the way because when Harry Reid got rid
of the filibuster for some of the
judicial nominees and then Republicans
came in and got rid of it for all
judicial nominees and put republican
nominees on the Supreme Court Democrats
learned the hard way that by busting
these Norms they set themselves up for
failure and I think that's one of the
reasons they didn't get rid of the
filibuster during the first two years of
Biden's term when there was a lot of
pressure to do it he's talking about
doing it still but they know now that
you could very well be on the other foot
after 2024 it probably will be in the
Senate because it's such a favorable map
but that's still that's that's stamp
collecting compared to what the
Democrats are doing correct they're
actively trying to imprison Donald Trump
at the federal level at the state level
in New York and in Georgia and the
Republicans are like don't forget the uh
Hague you know war crimes or crimes
against humanity they'll they'll you're
absolutely right they'll go after him
wherever they can and it's disgusting
um I think so the the the end result is
either Donald Trump goes in
immediately instructs his his new AG his
acting AG once he's once he's in to file
criminal indictments for all literal and
and provable uh criminal charges against
as many bureaucrats and politicians as
possible
we can't just sit back anymore and be
like
well you know we know they're corrupt
but going after him would destabilize
the system it's like you're kidding the
systems he stabilized no I agree with
you if you have literal and provable
criminal charges absolutely Obama killed
a 16 year old kid Cuomo Newsome Whitmer
who else do we got uh uh you know a
handful of Governors killed a bunch of
uh you know nursing home uh residents so
I think those right off the bat are are
plain and obvious you've got
constitutional violations in every
single blue state which does violate
federal law there's a federal law um of
a public official who intentionally
deprives someone of their constitutional
rights it's actually a crime so he could
actually indict all of them on all of
this heck he could even indict Ron
DeSantis not that that would go over
very well because Rhonda Santos was one
of the governors who actually lifted the
restrictions and let the state reopen
but in New York shutting down churches
and then when the Supreme Court was like
you can't do it he goes okay I'll just
issue another executive order and do it
again like oh come on at a certain point
it's like you're committing crimes and
abusing your power so I kind of feel
like that's the only path that that
results in any real change the end
result is if Donald Trump I I'm saying
outright
arresting people for for actually crimes
that they're indicted for I'm not saying
to randomly go in and just be like well
we're going to arrest them for no reason
I'm saying like actually be like okay
well that guy didn't actually do that so
you're good this guy clearly has a list
of things he's done is corrupt okay
we're gonna charge you we can't just sit
back and be like politicians are above
the law anymore especially considering
Democrats made the same exact argument
that's the game that we're playing right
now they say that well Donald Trump you
know may have uh filed the books wrong
so he's got to go to prison and I'm like
okay well Barack Obama blew up a kid in
Yemen Jail jail
if Donald Trump has to go to prison for
six months because he fought his books
wrong well it's unfortunate I look
forward to seeing Barack Obama serve
life in jail for killing Abdullahi if
you will put if putting Donald Trump in
jail for six months or whatever will get
Barack Obama in jail for killing an
American citizen I will I will drag
Donald Trump's ass to jail Kicking and
Screaming myself I will drag I will go
to to Florida and get him to put Obama
in jail for killing for violating the
Constitution absolutely absolutely but
beyond just that I mean he murdered more
than I think it was like four American
citizens I could be wrong I know Anwar
and abdulrahman yeah
what about George Bush Jr and Dick
Cheney oh yeah I mean are you kidding
see the problem is if you went into
office as the president you're like
schedule F I'm going after all of them
you hear me you're all indicted
everyone's indicted you'd Wake Up Dead
the next morning yeah you wouldn't wake
up the next morning you'd be dead no one
would lose their job yeah I disagree
well I don't know like no I I disagree
that we're not in the era uh we're in
the era of character assassination look
what they're doing to Trump they're
doing everything in their power to try
and stop them and you don't want to make
a martyr of people the CIA learned this
a long time ago they've turned that the
people they were trying to fight they
created Immortal statues of and they're
like okay we shouldn't do that anymore
so what do they do Julian Assange is a
good example they didn't Julian Assange
didn't wake up dead they just locked him
in a box for a decade accuse him of
being absolutely right that it is
character assassination that's why
they're trying to prevent Trump from
running for president yeah I think he
has a near zero percent chance of
becoming president let me ask you
something I don't know man like like
Epstein is dead so I mean I I do think
that they they will go with options
depending on the person so maybe you're
right about Donald Trump they would
maybe they would go for kids Epstein
wasn't a strong like public figure yeah
but the CIA is not over not above
killing people I'm not sure sure I get
it but what I'm saying is Epstein's not
a good example because he was trying to
be in the shadows let me ask you
something about the interference in
elections aspect of this so you asked
whether I would support the Sanders or
Trump and I hesitated but said I'd
support Trump I'm on record several
months ago as saying I would prefer to
see another candidate emerge for a
variety of reasons that aren't terribly
surprising but when they indicted Trump
I said you know this is forcing people
like me to become Trump voters whether
we wanted to or not because this is now
the issue if you can do this if you can
corrupt the system like this the only
way to protest against it is to make
Trump the president there's no other way
to do it
are we being
pushed into this is this a successful
Ploy by the Biden Administration to
craft an opponent that it thinks it can
beat they were wrong about that in 2016
as well but how do we react to that as
voters how do we reason through that I
don't I don't think the same strategy
would work I think they were lucky that
everything was locked down and people
had to vote by mail people didn't have
sports people didn't have movies people
didn't have entertainment the only thing
they could do was vote and so that they
hyper focused everything that will not
work again especially with the
horrifying job Joe Biden has done
there's no
you know they're showing all these polls
where they're like if it's Ron DeSantis
Biden loses but if it's Trump trump
loses and I'm like yeah yeah we get it
the machine there's elements of the
machine that really love Ronda Sanders I
like Rhonda Sanders I think he does a
really great job but boy do they hate
Donald Trump to the point where they
lied about all the polls not to mention
how many people are still secret Trump
voters who don't want to admit they're
going to vote for Trump I can tell you
this
I know of uh one celebrity family that
publicly is as liberal as liberal can be
and privately voted for Trump twice yup
and I can't I'm not going to say who
they are it's not my business but uh
there's there's tons of these people and
and the funny thing is a lot of these
celebrities taxes only reason legit only
raising taxes they couldn't tell you
about the culture War I was talking to
someone and they were like oh yeah
that's the celebrity guy in that movie
yeah he voted for Trump and the only
reason is that was because Trump was
going to lower his taxes only thing
cared about publicly
publicly he's on Twitter and like oh
Trump is so bad and he's like I better
vote for that guy you know what I'm
doing Joel is like um just trying to
keep an open mind and watch for the best
candidate because I think Vivek Rama
Swami is far superior mentally than
either Trump or DeSantis he's a money
almost a billionaire self-made by like
35 years old yeah he's amazing let me
throw out another name there
I had an opportunity to see most of the
potential contenders some of them have
already dropped out but last year at a
couple of meetings I was at Nikki Haley
had an energy when she was on stage that
was just different and interesting and
she's really struggling in the polls
right now and I know that a significant
portion of the conservative base doesn't
trust her but does she have a shot is
there some Lane where she can emerge
somehow out of this mess I imagine the
chat is freaking out right right now
good so what is it but let's let's talk
about it in 2024 that's Jeff Walsh Nikki
Haley is what they're freaking out about
the the Republican party is look the the
neocons fled to the Democratic party
they're not coming back and the
Republican party is is where it is now
it is the Trump party
so you can entertain anybody you want so
if if concern the Trump is made they're
like no he can't even run it's illegal
is that's in that reality which it looks
like we're headed towards I mean unless
you said New York jury is going to let
acquit this guy even if they convict him
I I think he's still he can run and I
think he you know for that reason I
think I would vote for Trump just to
so you know you can't do this to us I
seem to I don't know a lot about Nikki
Haley um I remember how has she been
political a long time yeah I actually
met her at a conservative blogging
conference this is way back in 2009 red
state which was one of the first
conservative blogs had a conference and
she was there so it was Ted Cruz people
who didn't hold any kind of real serious
public office I think he was solicitor
general of Texas or something but she
was just running for governor of South
Carolina and she came and talked to
these bloggers I met her got to know her
a little bit
I didn't think she was necessarily
qualified to be un Ambassador but Trump
put her in there she did a fantastic job
she's had some good things to say some
things I've been critical of and that
sort of thing but just the energy when
she's on stage and having I'll just put
it on the table having a female
candidate is different it's different
than what we're seeing and so it's
compelling for that reason again maybe
not compelling enough because she's
below five percent in the polls and that
sort of thing but yeah but you know are
there Alternatives again I say this as
someone who's also said if if they do
this to Trump there's no other option
you have to resist the system by voting
for him it's it's not even about the
issues anymore there's only one issue
and it's freedom and Justice in the rule
of the law and there's only one vote you
can take that's how I feel about it
let's let's jump back to the story about
Ralph yarl because we did deviate and uh
let's break this down we had to start
from the post-millennial surprise
surprise these people are lying again
Washington Post retracts false claim
that Ralph yarrow was killed in Missouri
shooting it's not the first time they've
done this where they've claimed that
some some story was someone was killed
when it was like no they're actually not
dead and this is another one why well
the story goes out as the saying goes
the lie travels halfway around the world
before the truth can strap on his boots
this story comes out from the Washington
Post where they say that this kid was
killed you get protests you get angry
you get animosity they then come back
and say whoops he's alive actually but
this is the story they've been pushing
in the media which to me makes uh almost
no sense why is this story
a national story is it sad sure you know
I I'm I'm sad when anybody gets shot for
something like this but I'll tell you
what I'll break it down for you simply I
think they're lying I'll tell you why
the story is Ralph yarl the black 16
year old boy who was shot twice after
accidentally ringing the doorbell of the
wrong home when picking up his brothers
is crying buckets of tears his mother
told CBS News full stop
he didn't accidentally ring the doorbell
he intentionally rang the doorbell at
the wrong house
so you see how that they're already
trying to frame it here he accidentally
rang the doorbell at this wrong house no
no he intentionally did it he
intentionally parked in the driveway got
of the house went there and it was just
the wrong house you can say he
accidentally went to this house
but he intentionally rang the doorbell
and went
up to the stairs and now here's here I
don't I think they've changed the story
several times
the uh let me see if I have the Tweet
here take a look at the original tweet
twitter preserved the metadata the
headline Kansas City teen shot after
entering wrong house
and that makes you wonder
why did they change the headline why did
they initially report that this kid
entered the home could it be that uh
they got it wrong the story is that the
man this guy Lester shot through the
glass screen door hitting the kid in the
head and I think in the shoulder or the
upper chest and that proves they say
that he needlessly just shot the kid
however
they mention uh let me see if
here we only read this they say Andrew
Lester the 84 year old white white
homeowner who shot Ralph knows they
always include the races turned himself
in Tuesday Etc Lester claimed the police
that he opened fire to the door of his
home without saying a single word
because he was scared to death of the
unarmed teen Clay County prosecutor
Thompson said Monday that there appears
to be a racial component of the case but
he clarified the probable cause
statement did not indicate that the case
was racially motivated according to the
charging documents Lester told police
after he shot Ralph that it was the last
thing he wanted to do but says he
believed he was protecting himself
against a physical confrontation which
he would not have been prepared for
given his Advanced age Lester pointed to
Ralph's size which he claimed was six
feet and Lester's inability to defend
himself as the reasoning behind his
actions the original story let me
actually uh pull up the archive so you
can see how they've manipulated this
said that the teenager
grabbed the door and was trying to open
it
and uh Time Magazine of course changes
the story so let me uh pull up the
archive pop it on over and we'll uh
we'll scroll down to what it originally
said and uh oh this is the original it
says the shooter's not identified
so even then wow they don't even have
the uh
the earliest version of the story
doesn't have anything in it this is one
of the problems with stealth editing so
let's jump back to uh the middle one
see if I can find where they wrote that
this kid didn't just ring the doorbell
but he actually tried entering the house
so let's uh we'll scroll down okay why
was the shooter released
man this is the hard thing about how
they keep changing the story you know
what I'll do I'll pull it up on my
Twitter so I saw that somewhere it may
have been on your Twitter but also they
keep changing the story this is the
problem with stealth editing it's so
annoying it's not like I'm trying to
pull it up this is all so soon after the
incident and we don't know most of the
facts if we've learned one thing from
these kinds of stories is you have to
wait for all the facts to come out but
as sad as this is
what really got me about it today was
when the White House started commenting
on it and they revealed that president
had called the victim which is
appropriate you know if you want to
express sympathy and that sort of thing
but Joe Biden told people not too long
ago during the whole gun control debate
after Trayvon Martin
Joe Biden told people to shoot through
their front door
if they wanted someone to go away this
is Joe Biden I don't know if you could
pull it up I think it was uh 2013 yeah
and conservatives made a big deal out of
it at the time because it's such
ridiculous advice that most reasonable
gun owners would know that that's really
stupid
just to shoot through a door without
opening it or whatever
he said that he gave his wife that
advice and that she was told to use the
shotgun just shoot through the front
door if you're scared
this guy followed Joe Biden's advice yep
so I want to correct you I actually had
the wrong link I had the wrong link but
they they do change the story but it was
a wrong link here's what it says
excerpts of the prosecutors probable
cause statement posted online reveal
that Lester told police he picked up his
gun after hearing the doorbell ring
while lying down he opened an interior
door and saw a black male approximately
six feet tall pulling on the exterior
door of his house believing it was a
breaking attempt he fired twice after
opening the door
man I have an anecdotal experience kind
of like this I went to my friend's
childhood friend's house four years ago
hadn't seen his parents in a couple
decades 15 years and they were like my
second parents growing up and I went and
I knocked he opened the door and I was
like Hey and he was like who are you and
I started to hug him and he got back and
was like who are you and I was a it's
Ian and he went oh but there was a
moment where if he was this 84 year old
if he was older 84 year old man maybe
he's been drinking his mind isn't where
it used to be
I mean wait for them to let you in every
time I this sounds like it was a big
accident it sounds like this came into
the wrong house it's not like he did
nothing wrong but they're turning into
this black lives matter racist thing
when the story is yo you go to an old
man's house and then you try opening the
door and gaining entrance to his house I
don't know about Missouri but in many
states people have the legal right to
use lethal Force to stop you from
committing a burglary yes burglary is
not about intention I don't think
burglary is just about the act of
entering isn't it I mean if you're not
correct yeah burglary is crossing a
property barrier so if that's the case
this kid was burglarizing that guy's
house and and well in the mind of the
homeowner no factually grab the handle
and started to open it but the guys
opened the door so maybe it seemed like
an invitation I mean this is sketchy and
the kid's not going to get charged with
burglary I would die no of course not
but but this is this this is the reality
I don't think there is in turn he's not
going to get charged there's no criminal
burglary but I think in terms of the
self fence claim there is an element of
burglary people think burglary means
theft it doesn't it means like crossing
a barrier onto someone's property so I
learned this the hard way if you have no
signs on your property anyone's allowed
to enter your property
they can't walk up to your house and
cross a barrier though however if the
screen like let's say let's say the door
is open they can walk in your house
they're legally allowed to and all you
can do is tell them to leave yeah if
your front door is open and no signs
people just walk in people are legally
allowed to walk into your home if the
door is unlocked clarified yep so if
unlocked or unlocked unlocked if it's oh
unlocked unlocked yup we dealt with this
one personally when we had when we had
someone come onto this property it
happened more than once
the police were like okay
entering the house is potentially
burglary in the lowest degree it's a
misdemeanor and here's what you get
because you're not supposed to enter
someone's house like that however they
still have an argument over why they
think they were entitled to enter the
house
if someone says there was no intent it
was an accident I went to the wrong
house you're not going to get criminally
charged so I'm not saying anyone can
just walk in any house they want if a
kid accidentally walks in the wrong
house there's no criminal charges
nothing happened if you put up a sign
that says no trespassing now they've
trespassed when they walk past it now
you can have them trespass which is a
slap on the rest and the police will
remove them if you take the thinnest of
string and wrap it around your front
yard
and someone steps over it they've now
committed burglary
that simple it's the craziest thing well
the other interesting thing about this
is what they didn't charge I heard the
family's attorney expressing concern
maybe outraged that the prosecutors
hadn't charged a homeowner with
attempted murder and they had just gone
for these other felonies that are short
of that and I think that's because the
police and the prosecution know that the
homeowner probably didn't have that
intent attempted murder requires right
intent to kill and and what the family
attorney wanted to see was some kind of
racial motivation that's what the
activists want to see they want to see
some kind of Criminal Intent some
criminal mindset and I think that the
authorities know that they don't have
that and I think it's probably closer to
what you're saying which is an accident
where maybe the homeowner wasn't legally
entitled to use lethal Force I think he
was
that's what they're going to fight out
and maybe they're just charging him so
they can start some kind of
investigation and satisfy the public
without people burning down Kansas City
or whatever but
look
this is all happening in
the shadow of a crime wave that's
happening not just there but throughout
the country where people are attacked in
their homes and in La we just had our
mayor propose hiring a thousand new cops
that's because Eric Garcetti her
predecessor bowed to the black lives
matter movement and cut 10 of the police
budget and then there's a crime wave in
Los Angeles and they wonder why right
and
I don't know what is in the mind of this
homeowner nor does the family attorney
of the victim but certainly there are a
lot of people who are living very scared
right now and that has to play into some
of this I mean there's got to be a
certain amount of tension
and again we don't know the motivations
we can't read minds but what we're being
told to do is to read minds what we're
being told to do is imagine that this
homeowner had some kind of racial bias
and that's why people get set on edge
about this stuff instead of just waiting
and hearing and listening to the facts
and look I think it's okay the president
called what about the victims he doesn't
call there are a lot of victims what
about Nashville did he call them no no I
think Jill Biden visited a vigil forum I
was looking that up but I don't know
about joking about it
well you know the president hasn't been
to East Palestine boom right here
yeah uh let me let me read the section
for you this is this is Missouri uh uh
you the stand your ground law and it
says uh you can use physical Force to
defend yourself yada yada section three
such force is used against a person who
unlawfully enters remains after
unlawfully entering or attempts to
unlawfully enter private property that
is owned or leased by an individual or
is occupied by an individual who has
been given specific Authority on the uh
Authority by the property owner to
occupy the property claiming a
justification of using protective Force
Under This section a person does not
have a duty to retreat from a dwelling
Etc so uh simply put
it says A person shall not use deadly
force upon another person unless the
circumstance is specified in subsection
one of this uh
under the circumstances specified in
subsection one of this section unless
and again such force is used against a
person who unlawfully enters remains
after unlawfully entering or attempts to
unlawfully enter private property the
legal questions if I could put on my law
school hat the legal question here is
going to be reasonableness so you see
the word reasonably appearing several
times in that
the question is going to be was the
homeowner acting reasonably yes and and
you may think so the question also then
becomes is it the mind of a reasonable
average person or the mind of a
reasonable 84 year old who lives alone
and may have dementia and that sort of
thing because right if it's like that's
that's what I mean right right so it
becomes a little bit different and
that's certainly why they didn't go for
attempted murder because I think they're
going to lose completely do you think
84. I think Dimensions should have guns
because they take their license away so
do you I mean he has to be second
amendment before you could say that he's
he's he right we're just expecting and
that's no one's saying he has to mention
but that's that's red flag law and I
think if you've got a problem with
Second Amendment you got to amend it
before you can take someone's guns away
even if they are 84. do you think that
we should consider no okay no I think
I'm not surprised he said that well I
mean if anybody needs a gun and defend
themselves it's someone who's yeah
that's totally true I mean like look I'm
a strapping young lad right I can defend
myself better than an 84 year old man
I'm not saying I'm gonna go you know
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu on anybody but I can
run I can jump I can throw a punch old
man ain't gonna be doing any of that
stuff he he needs he or she they they
need something to protect themselves now
here's what I think I think it's a
tragic story but you're an 84 year old
man and you see someone grab the door
and try to come in now they're trying to
illegally enter your property tempted
illegal entrance I mean look
when I first heard the story and they
claimed that this kid rang the doorbell
and you shot him I'm like that makes no
sense at all
oh and I got the quote Joel that you
were mentioning earlier from Joe Biden
uh this is from 2013 told Joe told Field
and Stream magazine quote if you want to
keep someone away from your house Joe
Biden said just fire the shotgun through
the door
I hate him so much he is so stupid this
guy should should cite that in his
defense yeah I hope his lawyers use it
and say look Joe Biden said but you know
look the reality is
the left right now is saying he rang the
doorbell and the guy shot him through
the door and it's like well where do you
get that account from where where did
that statement come from
I gotta be honest they didn't come from
the kid who was in the hospital
unconscious because he was shot in the
head it came from like it came from the
homeowner I heard and they then twisted
his words
they omitted the part where he said I
saw this you know this this young man
grabbing the door to open it and enter
my property the kid in his friend's
house and that and that and that sucks
man but he wouldn't go to the wrong
friend's house he was going somewhere he
was picking up his little brothers geez
now here's the issue if this guy does
get convicted I will tell you what's
gonna happen every single burglary in
home invasion is going to be a oops
wrong house I don't think he should get
convicted for this because the guy was
illegally attempting to enter his
property there's that's right he was
neither of them should get in trouble I
wonder if there's if there will be like
riots and stuff like that there are any
protests yeah protests but I wonder if
there'd be like riots and stuff
definitely you know there was a much
clearer they're writing for nothing in
Chicago right it's getting yeah it's
getting it's getting to that time of
year man a few years you guys remember
the Ahmad Aubry case where the jogger
was shot yeah excuse me jogger the
felony burglary suspect you mean
that's not a joke that's a fact
you know the
controversy there was a lot lower there
weren't protests right away and there
was more of a consensus that what
happened to him shouldn't have happened
that he was that he was chased down
um and I thought that what happened
there was interesting because the family
attorney didn't take the road of
encouraging protests they went to law
enforcement they worked with law
enforcement they didn't try to make a
big national issue out of it and that
attorney also interestingly also went to
the Trump White House and worked with
Trump on some of the criminal justice
issues and that kind of thing and it
wasn't rightly or wrongly whatever you
think of the verdict it wasn't a case
that divided Americans it wasn't a case
that was used by the movement even
though the black lives movement existed
it didn't become this divisive issue he
was that but that's because
conservatives are feckless
that story was clear-cut wrong and it
was funny that after the Kyle
Rittenhouse case you got a bunch of
conservatives coming out being like see
the Ahmed Aubry case proves that
conservatives aren't racist despite the
fact they knew nothing about the case
the dude wasn't a jogger the prosecution
and the defense never claimed he was
jogging and the the argument actually
was that well most people believed he
was the guy on camera breaking into
those homes and so the story The the
criminal case became did the McMichaels
have the legal right to commit a
citizen's arrest and the question to the
jury was do they need to be witnesses to
the crime or not and the jury decided
you must be a witness therefore the
citizens arrest was unlawful therefore
the death resulting from citizens arrest
is is Criminal
the fact that the guy who simply filmed
it got the rest of his life life in
prison proves that it was a complete
sham of a trial and a criminal case but
the fact that it didn't divide the
nation to me just proves that
conservatives
give up really easily or that they take
their points whatever they can and
they're not actually in this for the for
for the real the real long haul I think
a lot of the the media knowledge about
that case wasn't unveiled for me until
after it was over I didn't really learn
about the intricacies until well until
after McMichael was in jail
unfortunately right and that's the issue
conservatives didn't pay attention did
not care it wasn't broadcast it was it
was live yeah you could watch the trial
a lot what I mean is it wasn't covered
uh at Great length by the media right or
left the way that like the writtenhouse
trial was covered this quiet
neighborhood I'm sorry it's not true a
CBS they were running the show live it
was covered as extensively and the right
ignored the whole thing and then once
these guys got convicted a bunch of
conservatives were like see it was the
right call and like I think even Tulsi
gabbard came out was like praising the
conviction and I'm like
it some doesn't seem right about this
like why did all of these people just
come out and immediately side against
these guys without knowing anything
happened I'm not saying what they did
was a good thing they were told by the
police not to pursue Ahmed Arbury but
this idea that when when the Black lives
matter activists claimed a guy was
jogging and was hunted down by white
supremacists and lynched was a complete
and total lie and I'll say it you can
throw away all the facts of that case
and just say this a guy got in his car
saw the McMichaels driving their car to
chase after him so he picked up his
phone and filmed it they put that man in
prison for the rest of his life I cannot
even believe that that guy went to jail
and they did it because in my opinion he
embarrassed them and they and here's
what I think happened
the story died Ahmed Aubry dies and the
McMichaels say self-defense the police
say okay this guy was the felony
burglary suspect these guys did live
there that's what they assume happened
the guy driving his car apparently was
tired of getting crapped all over
because they were saying that they
chased him down or whatever so he goes
I've got the video and I'm gonna release
it so I think what happened was his
lawyer gave it to a radio host who then
put it online which ignited black lives
matter anger I think then the D.A said
you stupid mother
I'm gonna make you pay for doing this to
me what's that guy's name you know that
guy's name Brian something you can look
it up I forgot his name I think they
they did this because they were
punishing this guy for smearing them in
the National headlines and there was
just corruption
but there you go I mean even still
through this day they call that guy a
jogger it's like oh yeah 20 miles from
his house you know in a neighborhood
that's seeing a string of burglaries and
there's video footage from one of the
houses that was broken into which
appears to show Ahmed Aubry illegally
entering burglarizing the house
and then the media narrative as he was
jogging so you know William Bryan was
that his name 52 accused of joining
Gregory McMichael yeah as they chase
down Arbury he wasn't with them he
simply got in his car and started
filming and they said you know what
we're going to put you in prison for the
rest of your life for filming this
that's a lesson to everybody Roddy Brian
Roddy's nickname and it's funny when
like you look at their faces in the
trial when they're found guilty they're
like shocked how could this have
happened and that dude if he just did
not release the footage it was it was
self-defense the Ahmed Aubry runs up to
the McMichaels uh attacks him they fight
over the shotgun and then he gets he
gets shot and it's like I wish it didn't
happen I mean it sucks and there's a
there's a good argument to be made if I
was Ahmed Aubry and I had a car behind
me and I had a car in front of me I
might think fight or flight too so I can
understand that but this idea that he
was some innocent jogger is just
ridiculous and I I there you go but uh
the funny thing is
The Narrative is going to be the
narrative if conservatives aren't paying
attention don't know anything about the
case they're just going to say whatever
the left said because even talking about
Ralph yarl is entertaining the left's
decision to make this the national story
instead of that white woman who got
choke slammed by a by a mob of black
teenagers but if talking about the Ralph
Laurel case makes it so that neither of
these people are charged and Ralph
survives and maybe the two of them can
even make amends or something like that
would be
fantastic that would be agreed outcome
I'd like to say and the outcome I want
to see in the long run is we set the
narrative and we set the tone and we
decide what stories need to get National
prominence and I hope we get to that
point so long as we keep doing shows
like this and it gets the point where
New York Times or CNN can say take a
look at this instance of a shooting that
happens all the time but we decided to
highlight on racial grounds and then
everyone just says I'm not interested in
talking about that for the time being we
may be prominent in media but we're not
the corporate press and we're not as big
essay CNN despite the fact their ratings
are in the gutter YouTube puts them on
the front page so it's our job to debunk
their lives hopefully it will be the job
of some other young upstart to debunk
our mistakes and errors in the future
because we will be setting the narrative
hear that you're listening well I think
if I can just shift slightly here to
something I mentioned you before but
the job that this show does I think in
terms of providing Free Speech as much
free speech as we're allowed to have I
suppose is really really important and
the Kanye West show I think was a great
moment in journalism because rather than
following the herd of the mainstream
media and boycotting him and calling for
him to be shunned you allowed him an
opportunity to defend himself and he
walked away
whether that was real or not what we saw
as viewers was a debate that was fair
questions that were Fair free speech and
he couldn't handle it and he left and
that did more to debunk what he was
saying than Ari Emmanuel in Hollywood
organizing boycotts not just of
Hollywood people in his industry but
every industry thereby
mistakenly giving life to the conspiracy
theory that Kanye West was spinning so I
thought what you did was great and I
think that's an example for the young up
starts to follow you don't win by
shutting other people down you win by
opening debate challenging people and
you weren't even you know and especially
not Kanye West the thing with him the
boycotts were actually making people
double down on their support of him you
know they say that the the best way to
get rid of a bad idea is to put a
spotlight on it right everyone can see
how bad it is well that's the big
problem with censorship online it's got
it backwards it's trying to hide the bad
ideas so then they're going to percolate
grow and the pressure will build but if
you let them come out in an environment
where they can be communicated about not
just a one-sided you know guy on a
camera yelling but like in a round table
of people that are listening man it
changes the thing the thing about yeah
he's got a lot of people who just follow
him and are going to go along with what
he says because he's a billionaire
successful musician cultural icon
if you just shut him down all you're
doing is telling his core fans the only
information you can get is from him
you need to have him sit down and just
talk about these ideas because then
those people are going to be listening
to him say those ideas and go I don't
know if that makes sense you know you
can still like yay and be like I don't
know if what he said made sense but if
he he's never challenged because you
refuse to challenge him well then he's
going to win and we did a show or the
weekend I don't know if you guys saw it
we did a Tim cast IRL and then uh mines
on Friday at the Vulcan gas company
mines did an event on Saturday Destiny
was on Stephen Bonnell been on the show
a couple times and he was there
a challenging challenging challenging
even maybe even saying bad ideas I don't
know not saying you're saying but I'd
like to review the tape but the Alex
Jones came out Jack busovic was there
Libby yemons was there we had a
fantastic huge rotating group of people
coming in and out and it was it was
really nice to let let ideas show
themselves for what they are rather than
rather than demonizing the people that
happened to be the ones that have them
at that moment
yeah I digress we'll check out the video
If you haven't seen it it's on Steven's
Rumble channel so we see the uh that
video of that woman being choke slammed
and it's got I think like 12 or 13
million views so clearly it matters to
people and it's being shared like crazy
but uh where's the New York Times
headlines how could I think it's because
the video's so blurry I couldn't really
tell what was going on when I saw it
apparently do you really think that it's
just the blurriness is wise and not
being shared I really think it's
probably ideological from The New York
Times it could be but what they want is
clicks so if it's a video of a hand
going up and you see her eyes and the
struggle that's gonna get clicks and I
think that would get a lot of attention
I think that the video is dramatic
enough to get clicks because it has
million Tim just said it has a million I
think that there I really do think that
it's ideological it's clear what's
happening in the video too yeah if she's
there you can see her there and then
it's just pummeling from the top I don't
know I yeah I think she people are
arguing that they pulled her away and
then beat the other guy but I'm like you
don't know that you can say they beat
the other guy too but all I see her is I
all I see is she gets choked slammed to
the ground and then they start wailing
on you can literally see it it's it's
cool you can't see her getting hit but
you can't see her going anywhere like
she doesn't get up and walk away you
just get choke slime and then they're
pounding on someone on the ground yeah
that's the thing is you see everyone you
see her there and you don't see her
there and then you see people you know
punching towards the ground it's like
but you do see that being a guy they are
beating a guy you can see that guy
getting correct yes did she survive well
yeah okay so there's a question I have
about this also was which is were they
attacked or targeted because the guy she
was with
is black as well was it an interracial
couple that was targeted by the model no
or was it a gang they don't they don't
know it didn't look like she knew who
the guy was and it looked more so like
she just said like hey guys stop or
something like that and then they'd grab
her and she tried to get in between a
mob and a victim that is a well there
wasn't a whole lot of places she could
go I don't know maybe we should try and
figure out who this lady was and ask her
what happened yeah yeah she was like let
her tell the story I just saw a tweet uh
earlier someone they they are speaking
out uh I don't have any information
about it right now the woman is speaking
out the woman the woman and the people
that were attacked have been identified
and they have been speaking out uh they
were on Fox today I think Fox had the
exclusive and she said they were looking
for somewhere to eat oh they were
together they were I don't know if
they're dating they were they're
describing the headline as a couple I
guess that's where I got that idea let
me pull that up
what's that what's the headline it's mob
randomly attacks couple walking in
Chicago they said they were going to
kill us
and they say they were randomly attacked
yeah right yeah no you're completely
correct it is an iteration let's let's
roll with this we'll uh we'll cover the
story mob randomly attacks couple
walking in Chicago they said they were
going to kill us so it quite literally
is an interracial couple apparently
minding their own business when they
were violently attacked by a mob
they say they were randomly attacked
walking in downtown Chicago amid the
teen takeover Ashley and DJ said on
Tuesday they had been looking for a spot
to get food Saturday night when they
found themselves trying to navigate a
large crowd people in the crowd pushed
the couple and when DJ stood up to them
a fight fighting broke out as soon as
they pushed me I told DJ I said they
just shoved me and he asked them he was
like yo don't shove her who shoved her
and as soon as he said that everything
went crazy they said they were they were
going to kill us the mob pushed Ashley
to the ground and immediately turned on
DJ to beat him they robbed the couple
stealing their shoes phones and a pair
of glasses and Apple watch and a hat
video the attack during the violent teen
takeover of the city went viral oh okay
so it was a a mob of young black
teenagers mercilessly beating an
interracial couple what is this teen
takeover thing uh it can like four
consecutive nights of large groups of
teenagers in Chicago just rampaging
through the city setting fires and
smashing windows and attacking people I
think they tried breaking into the Art
Institute and got shot yeah a couple
kids got shot I don't know about getting
shot but they were trying to break in
the Art Institute in their work it's
fired a couple kids did get shot yeah uh
two of them and I thought it was because
they were trying to break it I'm not
sure
well you don't want teenagers
controlling your Society I'll tell you
that
well thanks Ian yeah you know this is
perhaps a racially motivated attack it's
not been described that way but oh no it
definitely is so to go to your point
about the double standard
we don't know what the motivations were
in Kansas City but there's an assumption
it had to be racial we have pretty good
evidence it might have been racial in
Chicago but we don't talk about that
well it's
yeah it was clearly a racist mob
attacking this interracial couple
because you know you can talk about it
but just don't talk about it too much
because then you're a racist and it's
okay the thing that offended me the most
about what the mayor-elect said
and others said was that these kids had
no other choice for entertainment on a
weekend because they come from deprived
backgrounds and they are impoverished or
whatever which is no opportunities no
opportunities right for recreation I
guess the parks were closed or something
I mean it's Chicago has so much to do
and these kids have phones and they have
cars and
you know maybe they're
they have some other frustrations and
challenges but it is it's awful it is
excused like that it is exhausting to
hear such obvious
shove down your throat all the
time to hear comments like that it is
just yeah I can't describe it as
anything other than just exhausting they
don't have anything to do so they have
to ransack the city give me a like the
likelihood that these people voted for
this is like 99
this is not a young conservative couple
sorry they probably either don't vote or
vote Democrat so I just like yeah we
don't want violent mobs to break out but
there's a I'm torn right like if Phil if
you voted
for the government to I don't know
um
give you a free car and then the
government gave you a free car back oh
wow look at that you know you voted and
got a car like who's paying for it I
have questions about like where it's
coming from if you voted for the
government to take your paycheck from
you and then they did I'd be like well
congratulations like you asked them to
do it they did you know it's like if I
ask a guy take the garbage out and he
does it why would I be upset about it I
don't like the metaphor if I voted for
them and they're perpetuating the the
violence so I'm responsible because you
voted for Obama I voted for Obama and
then I realized it was a mistake and
then I didn't vote for him with your
argument they'd be like well you're it's
because of you that 2008 to 12 happened
yeah you're responsible that's a fact it
is you killed those kids like that's
what yes my support for Barack Obama and
what pissed me off and made me so
extremely angry with Democrats was that
yes I gave Obama the support he needed
to murder children but you did
and that pisses me off yes technically
yeah yes I did but you didn't do that
with that intention of course not it
doesn't matter if I give someone a brick
and then they say hey give me that
breakfast say okay and then they start
hitting something I'm gonna be like yo I
shouldn't have given them that break got
Authority you gave me Authority but any
president would have had that Authority
that's the reason that I feel terrible
about voting for Bush because of the war
in Iraq like that's why people like
change their votes they're like they
vote for someone because they're hoping
for something the person they voted for
gives them a pile of because that's
what they do and then people like well I
don't want to vote for them anymore
that's that's just the normal thing that
people that's why people are so sick of
the government after that I didn't vote
in 2012 or 2016 because I was like I
don't want to be responsible for what
these do and then Donald
Trump did a bunch of really great things
with the economy and really great things
with foreign policy to the point where I
said this guy needs another term I mean
the foreign policy stuff was so good
that I was finally like okay this guy
actually did these things he also set up
a clandestine drone Network where he
gave his General authority to bomb
whoever they want in secret that's right
but I look at what he did as he was
working more to pull the us out of what
other people started and I can certainly
recognize with that comes the collateral
damage that George W bush created I
don't even I don't even necessarily want
to blame Barack Obama for for starting
the wars that George W Bush started I'm
with you there but he did sign off on
these things Donald Trump did as well
and I think he should be held
responsible however the reason I liked
what Donald Trump was doing was that he
was actively pulling it all back can I
ask you something about the foreign
policy issues because you were there
documenting the Occupy Wall Street
movement the anti-war movement was a big
part of the motivation for Obama's
victory in 2008 whether he said so
explicitly or not people had the idea
this guy was going to get us out of
Bush's Wars and that kind of thing Along
Comes Donald Trump doesn't go to war
four years of Peace Putin doesn't invade
anybody
and Abraham Abraham Accords and the left
brain negotiation nobody gives him I
mean I shouldn't say nobody there's
Glenn green wall there's a few questions
there's a few other people give him
credit but the left for whom this was
the issue or so I thought decided that
they had to get rid of trump and now
we've got Biden risking on every front
yeah pro war as they come so I mean what
happens to the anti-war movement where
is the left with this did they just
forget about it do people Mumble and
walk away what happens I feel part of
that making it I'm part of that movement
I feel like it is Unstoppable that the
military-industrial complex controls our
country and that it's we're just in a
military autocracy
and and stop full stop I don't know what
else to do I used to dismiss that view
but when I see
just observing the FBI interference and
the Intel leaks and the Russia collusion
plot and how there was the hunter Biden
Russian disinformation letter and this
collusion between elements of our
intelligence community and the
Democratic party I can't dismiss that
anymore I feel like well we have this
democracy but it's as much as they allow
us to have and you can't elect the wrong
candidate otherwise as Chuck Schumer
warned they will get at you a hundred
different ways and just pull it out from
under you which is what they did
but I mean but how do you look at that
if you're on the left how do you look at
that and say wait a minute I don't like
Trump and I can even think he's a racist
but I can't go along with what they're
doing the left doesn't have principles
there there is no there is no moral
framework that exists among the left in
fact I think what makes the left
distinct is a clear lack of a moral
framework that's it but I have friends
and relatives who are leftists and they
believe these things with good
intentions they believe they have a
moral framework I can't say to them well
you disagree with me because you have no
morals but they don't right so someone's
arguments are different from what they
actually do so like
they have no legitimate reason for
supporting war with Ukraine none there's
no more there's no moral basis for that
well it's the fear that he's gonna go
from country to Country to Country and
this is the first one like Hitler went
into Poland but there there there's no
unless you outright say like I think the
United States should take over the world
should be actively you know et cetera et
cetera Empire nation building whatever
you can't be on the left opposing George
W bush opposing expansion of war and
then be supporting Ukraine that proves
you have no moral framework other than
there is no truth but Power lately I've
been like well I've stopped taking the
the view of hey stop doing the war quit
that I no longer do that anymore now I'm
like how can we redivert resources so
that the military-industrial complex can
remain super profitable yeah and we can
Ally with Russia and make more money for
everybody like there's got to be a new
not just stop and don't that won't work
anymore it's right it's moving so I I'm
sorry I lost what I was saying because
Ian so well you know what just sorry I
have a different I'm not anti-war I'm my
point real quick I was I wanted to see
what you hear what you had to say my
point was the left has no moral
framework because they say we oppose
George W bush yeah I feel like I feel
like I understand what you're saying I
feel like the reason that they're oh I
think that the left is okay with global
government with a global government
because the left is it like the the left
is where communism comes from and that's
and you don't get real communism unless
you have like Global communism so I
don't think that the the left isn't okay
with that kind of stuff and I do think
that the left is okay with expansive
governments and stuff like that because
that's how you end up with a global guy
do you think the average
but I don't think that I don't think
that it makes I understand what you're
saying when they when you say that
doesn't make sense for this particular
war in general do you think the average
Democrat voter supports communism no I
think the average Democrat voter is the
is the default leftist which shows
there's no moral framework among the
left you can say that some elements of
the left are communist yeah but when the
majority of their voter base doesn't
know or care or pay attention yeah
there's just no moral framework that's
the default that's the difference
between leftists and Democrats is that
you can vote for the Democratic
candidate and be completely politically
ignorant that then you're not a leftist
but if you're politically active and
you're into that kind of thing you
become on the left it's the activation
of political ideology that puts you in a
right or left concept whether you're a
Republican or Democrat well you might
just be completely apolitical Andrew
Breitbart called it the default liberal
I believe that's that was the saying
that's that's that's what I think about
the corporate press I think he's I think
Brett was was totally on it right with
that the Democrats the party of the nice
voters so yeah we definitely got to go
super chats we went a little long so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you do like it and head over to
timcast.com click the join us button to
become a member we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you at about 10 10 p.m and if you
are a member for at least six months or
sign up for 25 bucks you can submit
questions and potentially be one of our
callers they call into the show and talk
to us on the show everybody can hear you
you get to be on the show with us let's
read your super chats all right
Pittsburgh says Hey Joel what are your
thoughts on graphene
I don't even know what it is that's my
thought oh oh boy I've got some right
now
it's a hexagonally lattice carbon that
can be used as a metamaterial yeah it's
a one atom layer thick of carbon like in
a honeycomb okay Strand and it's a
superconductor super strong that's
capacitive like a battery you can make
touch screen wallpaper out of it I have
clothing that's made out of it it's like
and it's made from pure carbon so you
can get it from carbon dioxide well
while we're here I'll just say this
they've uh new batteries they've been
putting together lithium ion they've
been actually creating uh graphene
Network in it to create a graphene
composite battery they charge something
like 20 to 30 times faster so there you
go let's read some more Super Chips
Raymond g Stanley G says Tim you did it
your big time Elon subscribes to you now
Hells Bells but sir please don't forget
this one important thing Luke beat you
to it well handyman I don't know Elon
can follow it whoever wants here's a
graphing I did a I did a video about
Elon and the CBC and you can see it says
Elon subscribes to you on my Twitter he
responded to Luke earlier today oh about
what they're cute
um Luke posted a video of like this
Supermarket that had been ransacked and
Elon is like looks like Fallout the game
well uh I'll just say it I'm like oh he
follows me I hit him up and I was like
I'd really love to do a Twitter 2.0
conversation like I asked Joe the same
thing look in terms of guys on the totem
pole I'm at the bottom here it's Joe
Rogan it's Elon Musk let's start off on
our Twitter space but I I mean yeah I
mean that's that's the opportunity to do
a Twitter space actually Mario Mario
novel I think is his name uh he does
Twitter spaces and he's done with with
Elon maybe he could yeah but I'm but I'm
I'm like look we did uh Joe uh myself
Jack and Vijay did that whole Twitter
conversation and doing the same
conversation but with the new boss yeah
I think would be really really great but
uh it's up to them yeah to host the
Twitter comment talking Elon set up a
host where you host it and he'll come in
maybe I mean we've got the iPhone set up
here because we're actually thinking of
launching some kind of space thing for
IRL figuring it out but you know we'll
see we'll see all right let's see we got
what do we got what do we got
Senor poodle says
please talk about that woman who was
attacked during the recent Drago rides
that video is beyond enraging we did we
talked about it
hunter killer says I think the left is
pushing the KC shooting to a push to get
rid of stand your ground laws and B
distract from events like this past
weekend in Chicago I completely agree
and ask questions like should an 84 year
old man have a gun yes because he's the
one who actually needs it and uh it's
another issue of when we're living in
dense populated areas these things will
happen and you don't want to live here I
mean look man I said this earlier if in
the middle of the night it's like it was
after 10 p.m this happened so if it's
like maybe at the middle of the night
but it's it's 11 P.M we've got armed
guards here if someone walked up to the
house that was not on our like expected
list and known list and they they walked
past our perimeter and tried entering
the house I don't think they would get
shot but you better believe they
probably have a gun pointed in their
face and they'd be instructed to back
away get on the ground like we've been
swatted 15 times we have death threats
now the difference is this is not some
like simple private residence it's a big
office with a bunch of people who are
working here so it's a bit different but
yeah if someone randomly showed up and
tried entering the house would not go
well for them at the very least they
might get detained and hurt in the
process and uh I advise people stay away
as for this old man
a stranger went to his house and tried
opening the door and he panicked yeah
that's the thing that gets me he tried
to open the door even if you're picking
up your your little brothers or whatever
it was his cousins why would you open
the door like for what for real and this
is an important Point too
there's no argument for that none you're
given an address you clearly don't know
what the building looks like why would
you try to walk into the front door
without knocking first I mean I agree
100 and it's just like the kid made a
boneheaded decision because you I
imagine the kids not like looking to
like he's going there to help you know
find his brothers and sisters or
whatever so it's not like the kids
trying to hurt someone or trying to
break in or whatever it's just the kid
was like oh and he made a bonehead it
sounds like he made a bonehead decision
and tried to go in to get his brother
and it sucks but I don't imagine that
the guy was just like oh here's my
chance no it's 11 o'clock we got a house
picture in the day before I gotta read
this backhanded compliment of uh Phil
Joseph Ramo says wanted to tell Phil
Labonte that as a hardcore dude I'm glad
that I'm not the only nun leftist in
heavy music culture sorry for writing
you guys off as butt Rock after your
second album second album that I would
be surprised but I mean that's uh no
hate no hey just you know take a listen
to her stuff I don't at all what's butt
Rock butt rock is uh Nickelback yeah you
know because it's like poopy no well
it's just it's a it's a meant to insult
yeah like generic rock bands like
Nickelback I like Nickelback
Nickelback's uh uh uh The Devil Went
Down to Georgia is amazing I've talked
I've I don't I don't play this stupid
like you better fit in by claiming to
hate the things we hate stuff it's so
stupid what's that better off yet is
that the name of their song that there's
a lot better off there there's there's
the new song is a song called San
Quentin it's awesome they're just
awesome I'm not I'm not a big fan so
funny reputation because they had long
hair they were like just so like exactly
what you would think of in that scene at
that time they're awesome like I agreed
like you really couldn't tell apart if
you weren't part of that that scene it's
the crazy thing I've never been a big
fan or anything like that but like the
idea that the left one day decided they
hated Nickelback and then everyone had
to hate them I'm just like I think they
got overplayed it was so simple with
Hootie the Blowfish but they didn't get
it like Nickelback No it started it with
a protest of Rahm Emanuel and someone
held up a sign saying Rahm Emanuel likes
Nickelback and that set the tone
Nickelback was bad and the left now said
if you like Nickelback you're bad and
Maya 2 is kind of like I don't know they
got that one good song it was a hit like
for six weeks or something Devil Went
Down to Georgia a legit good song the
rest of stuff I just don't listen to I
don't know I got no issue with them
there's a lot of bands I don't listen to
I don't Smack talk them why would I
that's stupid yeah yeah lift musicians
up Now's the Time I like Soundgarden
recently I've been listening to them a
lot all those things
almost hit the highest note in the song
and people are here in the house that
can verify that
they can and we'll get you up there they
know you're working on it I'll give you
some give you some workouts we'll get
you up there all right let's see where
we are at
T-Rex Pet Shop says big corporations are
realizing the consequence of joining the
culture war and none come out unharmed
we haven't even face we have even faced
backlash for being anti-woke we will not
be moved stop supporting woke bet stores
Tim we still haven't been paid with our
money ha ha ha oh we gotta I don't know
what the next thing is we gotta order
for for uh bogus so I don't know thing
what do you mean thing well from T-Rex
we needed food well he's on that very
special diet so I don't I don't know
okay he still seems like he's sick but
no he's gained weight he's like gained
0.3 pounds or something he looks great
have you seen him I went and said what's
up to him earlier he was screaming yeah
yeah I mean relative to where he was at
he was phenomenal but he's bored as hell
in the he's stuck in the room like you
think about it like you know three or
four months ago the everyone was like
bogus is done he's gone dude you know in
in December whatever we were told he had
two weeks and when he came back to us he
couldn't stand up he tried to to go in
the litter box and he fell and then just
crapped on the floor and that's why I
made that video where I was like this is
it like he got to the point where he
couldn't stand up he would try and stand
and then he would just like flump over
to the slump to the ground we got him
the new diet food we got him the
hydration uh injections and he got a
hormone treatment that stimulated red
blood cell production and he started
getting better and then Ian got him the
experimental stem cell therapy oh thank
you that's amazing Hopewell Medical
Hospital Animal Hospital in New York man
in Hopewell New York like it was nice to
take a week away in Austin because I got
to see bucko before we left and after so
like if you see everybody every day you
don't notice the changes but a full week
of a way he got puffier like his fur is
a little puffier he looks a little
bigger little fat hanging off his sides
I like it yeah I was here I'm talking in
uh in the main room he wants out all
right Phil dude bro says what you guys
don't realize Bud Light has a whole line
of hard seltzers with girly flavors and
they want to Outlaw menthol cigarettes
okay
dorktanian says it's a Benjamin Crump
story Tim the same lawyer activist who
is behind a multitude of the BLM Bowl
that's right a lawyer yes he is oh God
what a garbage man
yep he's the worst it's just when I
first heard the story I was like why is
this news I mean like it's a tragic
story but this thing happens all the
time I'm sure there's probably 50
stories just like it right now
and notice how the media immediately
wanted to be about race
they wanted it they wanted it badly the
other thing was at the White House
briefing today reporters were asking the
press secretary for a statement about
what this says about America so we are
all to be judged by this one incident
which could turn out to be
you know a bone-headed move by the
kid or a terrible mistake or worse by
the homeowner but somehow it's all of
our fault like this says something about
us collectively that's not the
politicians saying that those those are
the so-called journalists we have one uh
from Gabriel Lopez he says yes women
will vote for their own demise as men
it's our job to protect them even from
themselves the 19th was a giant
anti-woman move they should not be
diving in the pile of garbage that his
politics look at their results uh I I
completely disagree I think women
absolutely should have the right to vote
I think individuals matter most but I
will say of the 19th I do take issue
with it
the 19th Amendment says you cannot
discriminate on the basis of sex
you know what that means it means trans
people can have the right to vote
rescinded because it's not protected of
the 19th Amendment the 90th Amendment
says sex not gender I think we should
just repeal the 19th eliminate all that
language and just we don't need an
amendment telling people who's allowed
to vote right right I mean in all
seriousness I don't understand why we
need an amendment to be like an
individual has the right to vote you
want an amendment that says who is
you're not able to stop from voting
like you shouldn't be able to stop
people from voting that's basically what
the the Constitution should show I would
like to see an amendment that or I would
like to see a requirement for Citizens
we talked about service yeah uh I think
his answer was simply put
sign up for the Selective Service and
you get your voter ID card
I'm I'm pretty much okay with that I
mean unless we can figure out a way to
have no one vote then you know yeah no
voting for anybody nobody does Donald
Trump becomes president and that's it
and then we you know make him a cyborg
and then upload his brain to an AI and
then from now on you have cyber Trump
and then and we tell them and we tell
them if if they mess up we're going to
pull the plug Cybertron versus Mecca
Biden would be cool
for cyber truck yeah sure who would win
seven armed Cruz says Tim I'm one of
those filthy beer drinkers I would like
to thank you for letting me know about
Modelo being owned by Bud Light I would
also further thank you for introducing
me to Yingling oh good yeah I I misspoke
I said I thought Yingling may have been
partially owed by Anheuser it is not
it's actually a traditionally owned
family business that has been passed
down from generation to generation for
like 200 years yeah literally Junior 200
years and uh not to mention I actually
think healing tastes really good and um
I like the beers that I like to drink
Blue Moon I like Modelo I like and uh
Yingling I like dude other thing sucks
so much I know that's why what whatever
because Modell's on half of it I believe
half of it is owned by Anheuser-Busch by
inbev or whatever and so it's a it's a
bummer but uh I don't drink beer anyway
so you know I'm not going to be drinking
any of it but uh if I had to choose a
beer it'd be Yingling nice that's just
me I mean it's really good America's
oldest brewery it's also made in Philly
right yep yeah it's like Pennsylvania
real traditional American they made a
commercial they made an ad that's a
picture of the Yingling with the
American flag yeah I saw it so you know
I'll take it that's good but like I I
people have mentioned that uh I could be
wrong about us I don't know there was
pictures of of a pride flag with
Yingling and chorus and all that stuff
and I'm like I don't know or care if
that's true because I got no problem
with it I I don't care
you know right what I care about is like
specifically Dylan Mulvaney being a
really really evil person
all right let's let's see let's see we
got we got some more news oh we also do
have really big news that we're gonna
have on the members only show that um
for obvious reasons not going to be on
the main show the FDA announced that
they're I'm gonna be careful the
language here a major announcement was
made on whether or not you can get the
uh
mRNA vaccines
oh I know what you're talking about yeah
and because the language is extremely
confusing and uh they they put out like
six tweets on that contract each other
I'm gonna be careful about the language
I use on YouTube because YouTube's full
of crap but uh they basically made an
announcement about certain vaccines you
are no longer allowed to get and I
wonder if this coincides with the end of
the national coveted emergency meaning
emergency use authorizations are
officially out the window
you can't have an eua on something if
there's no emergency I guess but we'll
talk about that in the members only
portion so make sure you go to
timcast.com click join us let's read
some more Super chats
North Georgia infantry says April is
Confederate History Month
is that true
is that true I don't know
I mean I like Civil War history is
absolutely fat and fascinating I think
it's yeah I love that you're talking
about Harper's Ferry earlier did you see
the battery the uh the old weapons uh
hold I think it's called a battery but
it was just leveled all there is is just
like concrete based now it was
completely leveled To The Ground by the
Union Soldiers when they came in yeah
it's fascinating I mean what also I
think or maybe it's interesting about
the town is there is a bed and breakfast
you can actually stay at that used to be
Stonewall Jackson's headquarters when
the Confederates took over the town they
haven't erased any of that history it's
just layer upon layer upon layer it was
the Armory that's what it was yeah
there's a really awesome little coffee
shop uh in Harpers Ferry that I love
going to I'm gonna shout them out let me
look up go up the hill to that church
that's like blown out and that's like I
guess there was like a Last Stand or
there was like stands up there were
dudes would just like pulled out on the
top of the hill there were so many
battles there it was taken over five
times I think they have this by
different armies within the Civil War
right went back and forth and you got
John Brown of course and uh the NAACP
being there and just so many different
things you could learn so much about
American history from one town and again
it just shows you the value of
preserving these things and not
rewriting history because parts of it
offend you or parts of it are difficult
I mean John Brown was
difficult for his age he was an
abolitionist who took up arms arguably
pushed the United States towards Civil
War later celebrated as more of a hero
but how many different perspectives were
there about that guy at his time you
can't cancel any of that stuff and still
learn from it Battlegrounds shut up oh
the coffee shop yeah Battlegrounds
coffee because there are so many
Battlegrounds on that Ridge
strategically massively important
location Good Neighbor coffee shop too
yeah yeah but they do a really really
awesome uh
BLT or it's not a BLT it's like bacon
lettuce tomato and egg if you guys have
not been to Harper's Ferry you have to
you have got to visit Harper's Ferry
there's I've never seen any City like it
before it is incredible it is it is very
so many cool businesses in that town
like little shops and restaurants you
see on the mountain they've carved an
advertisement anything like that that is
wild and they're like well we oops we're
not going to do that again because it's
there forever like that's some good good
uh placement all right let's read some
more Super chats
what do we got here
William Jones says Tim look at Tech Nine
song drama help you understand KC PS
Tech a rapper from KCMO
interesting
all right free men Die free says
Nickelback is the GOP of Music popular
when it shouldn't be Discord is lit
right now by the way oh very cool yeah
become a member go to timcast.com click
join us get access to our Discord server
hang out with like-minded individuals
and uh got some news from the state on
the Poker Club apparently they are not
go they only allow a certain amount of
gaming licenses so we likely would not
be able to have a poker club and they're
very strict on home poker games so you
can't even do it Texas style but I'm
actually wondering if that's
constitutional uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna get a little aesthetic with
you guys I really want to say this
poker is uh for those that play it's
extremely popular obviously it's getting
more popular by by the minute the World
Series of Poker had like 11 000 entrants
so it's really starting to in my view
pick up obviously I'm I got into it in
the past several months watching these
videos online
but mostly because I've always played it
I've always played Magic the Gathering
what I don't understand is
it's a game where you choose your odds
you choose your probability you can
choose to play or not to play it's a
skill game there is Chance involved but
Magic the Gathering Pokemon Yu-Gi-Oh all
these card games are skill and chance
games
why is it that in West Virginia in
Maryland and Pennsylvania in every
single state I can take a deck of cards
I can then pay money to a facility
to enter me into a contest where I cross
my fingers and I'm going to get a good
draw of my cards and get the right cards
that I need to win and then if I do win
I get paid cash for it is that not
gambling
Magic the Gathering is a game of partial
chance it's a skill game for sure but if
everyone's playing the Pokemon Yu-Gi-Oh
you name your card game in fact I think
poker is actually more more reasonably
Fair because there's no barrier for
entry yeah you're always using the same
deck exactly imagine the Gathering which
is the most popular physical card game
there are tournaments where people can
make tens of thousands of dollars you
pay 500 bucks to enter a tournament you
play against people cross your fingers
you draw a good card because it's random
chance and it's even kind of worse
because if someone else has a lot of
money and they've bought the best cards
you have less of a chance of winning
exactly buying a good deck in Magic
requires you to be wealthy which is just
a disadvantage so it's it's worse than
poker poker is the same deck the same
odds everyone's playing the same game
and if you got the skill you can figure
out what the person's trying to do and
if you can win or not it it's it's skill
based with chance in the side Magic
Gathering has so many layers but but I'm
not trying to rag on Magic I like magic
my question is why is one legal and one
not legal when they're both effectively
the exact same thing and and you can
make the argument that you're not
wagering cash in between each turn but
you what poker tournaments are still
illegal yeah in a tournament you would
pay money up front and then you just
wage your chips which represent I guess
the cash but they don't because points
yeah but doesn't matter still illegal
can't can't do it so I think there's a
lot of Governor I think there's a
lawsuit brewing in that it's an
unconstitutional move to single out one
card game and not others so they either
have to make Yu-Gi-Oh illegal or make
poker legal I'm not talking about
playing Blackjack I don't want to play
Blackjack or these table games I'm
talking about friends playing against
friends so the the what I was talking
with uh Allison earlier and I'm like why
don't we just do this we'll make a card
game called Wizards and warriors where
there's four elements there's there's
water fire earth and uh wind and there's
13 14 creatures that fight no no no
there's uh uh elemental power so you
have power levels one through nine yeah
exactly then you have power levels Jack
queen king and Ace as well absolutely
something else I mean the aces of fire
the kings of fire the we can call them
whatever and then what you're doing is
you're trying to cast a spell against
your opponent and like three of a kind
you need to pair exactly basically it's
poker rules but we'll just make it
they're playing we're playing d d or
something I mean we have to tweak a
little bit of the rule you can really
just you can really just make them like
make the cards have like pictures
instead of the the numbers and stuff on
them but it's like oh I've got uh level
five of fire and I've got three level
five fires so they've synchronized
giving me a triple fire blast that
defeats your double fire blast I take
all of the money you know what I mean
yeah if you just add a weird mystical
element to it all of a sudden it's it's
a it's a it's a trading card game yeah
it's fine it's so dumb all right Nathan
C says Yingling is PA Coal Miner's beer
My World War II vet Grandpa used to
drink it he was a master Carpenter and I
think he did a bit of mining when
younger True Grit drinking some now on
my birthday cheers happy birthday Nathan
man happy birthday rip Jew says please
bring bocus on so we can see him
healthier I could do that you want to
grab him for the member zone I will yeah
all right everybody smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member one of the members only
uncensored show in about 10 minutes and
uh if you sign up at the 25 level or
you're a member for at least six months
you can submit questions and even call
into the show and join us so smash that
like button as I mentioned you can
follow the show at timcastirl basically
everywhere follow us on Facebook and
Instagram you can follow me personally
at timcast everywhere Joel do you want
to shout anything out
yeah I've got a new book out it's the
biography of my mother-in-law who passed
away a year ago Rhoda and she was an
anti-apartheid activist opposed racism
in South Africa was appointed to the new
government by Nelson Mandela and then
resigned in protest over that
government's failures became one of the
most vociferous critics of that
government and from starting out as a
black feminist she became a trump
supporter so very interesting political
Arc and a fantastic person we lost her a
year ago but she left a legacy and you
can read about it in the book you know
surge is from South Africa where are you
from Serge
um do you remember where my parents are
from yeah my father's from patanco
Belfast which is north of Johannesburg
maybe like an hour half and then my mom
is from Pretoria okay so yeah North the
northern part yes yeah my wife was born
and raised in Cape Town I was born in
Johannesburg but grew up in Chicago wow
people are saying don't put Focus behind
a paywall if you want to see bogus you
gotta pay you Phil you want to shout
anything uh I am Phil that remains on
Twitter I am Phil that remains official
on Instagram the band is All That
Remains on all of the uh Spotify Apple
music all that stuff I mean at crosland
follow me at Ian crossland.net and also
I want to shout you out Joel your
Twitter anyway Joel Pollock
p-o-l-l-a-k people can follow you there
thanks for coming it was really
enjoyable actually and I feel like in
the amount of time we had we we just
kind of got started and looking into
your brain I really love it so thank you
for coming I'd love to talk about if we
can in the members only let's talk about
Occupy Wall Street and Andrew Breitbart
and yeah absolutely how we got here
awesome we also have Serge duprea
yes I'm a mute there hi guys uh
surge.com on Twitter uh that's all we
will see all of you over at timcast.com
it'll be up on the front page in about
eight minutes thanks for hanging out